his name is robert paulson his name was
robert paulsen is robert paulson
potato potato i i did i made that
mistake too i typed in the chat first
his name was and then i looked up to be
sure and it's actually the line is his
name is robert paulson and of course
that is a tribute to meatloaf who passed
away he was he was a rad dude he was a
legendary uh rock star he was in fight
club and that was the reference we made
to him and he was also pro-freedom he
opposed the mandates he opposed mass
mandates and vax mandates he stood up
against him
apparently he criticized greta tunberg i
don't know if that matters as much but i
really respect that he you know he was
he was an older guy he was 74 and he
said that he wasn't going to live his
life in fear and they shouldn't shut
down the world for politics and that's
what they're doing and i respect that
and he got seriously ill with kovid
and that was his choice i'm sure you're
going to get all those herman cain award
people you know laughing at him but
these people don't understand what
freedom means it means if i want to
choose to go bungee jumping i can choose
to go bungee jumping there's danger if i
want to choose to go skydiving and my
shoot doesn't happen i made those
choices and meatloaf stood up for
everyone else's freedom he chose up for
his freedom and he knew the risks so you
know what mad respect to meatloaf sad to
see him go but you know he was 74. so we
got a bunch of other news too we got uh
joe rogan that that hoax list where they
were like 270 doctors and it turned out
to be like 80 doctors and like some
dentist or something the list is now
bigger
and now it's a thousand medical and
science experts yeah yeah yeah okay
we'll talk about that stuff we'll talk
about culture and censorship we've got
two really big stories joe biden has
lost another court battle a federal
judge has struck down the federal worker
mandate for vaccines and we have a new
report from reuters saying that
prior covet infection provides better
immunity during the it did provide
better immunity during the delta surge
which we can then take data from that
extrapolate and apply it to the future
seems like luke was right on this one
and i was wrong that uh they're gonna
start easing up the the mandates but
we'll see we'll it's yet to be seen here
in the united states so we'll get into
all this stuff joining us today is
christian toto
you want to introduce yourself sure i'm
the editor of hollywood in toto.com and
my new book is called virtue bombs how
hollywood got woke and lost its soul so
we can talk a lot about this cultural
stuff you know particularly i think
you're an expert on that that'd be
that'll be awesome we've got libby evans
joining us tonight hi here i am i'm the
editor-in-chief of the post-millennial
glad to be back
and uh hey guys my name is lucadaski if
we are change.org and today i am wearing
my make america florida shirt which you
could get on the best political
shirts.com but i'm also wearing it
because in a few days from now i will be
moving to miami florida and i am
extremely appreciative and grateful for
all of you amazing human beings a part
of this broadcast and podcast hopefully
i could come back maybe during uh the
spring maybe during the fall we'll see
but i i want to do a lot of amazing
things in florida i want to do some cool
projects if you guys want to get
involved with that hit me up you guys
know my contact information and i will
definitely miss you guys in the
conversations and everything we've been
able to achieve here it's been a wild
ride
it's it's it's it's okay look you know
luke got really scared of what's been
going on hey no no no i was like
i gotta get out of here and we're like
come on let's be fine i was trying to
leave for so long but then but then the
threats came and then the swatting came
and then and i was like i can't look
like a punk i gotta stay a little bit
longer and a little bit longer uh but uh
seriously very appreciative of of
everybody and everything and it's going
to be sad to go but we were wrapping up
a show and then luke goes i'm gonna be
leaving right as all these threats are
coming and people are going to think i'm
scared
i can't do that and then i kept
postponing it
but uh you know
that happens that's part of the nature
of luke uh he migrates with the seasons
i just wanted to clarify i'm not going
out for cigarettes right
um if you guys want us to maybe go down
to florida for a week or so maybe party
with luke and do a show down there put a
five in the chat five five in the chat
for that smash the like button smash it
yeah and if we get enough likes then
we'll take the new uh mobile studio down
to florida and uh we'll do the show down
there for the sound of that uh i'm ian
crossland you follow me in crossland.net
and i will see you soon i'm going to
make sure to pierce those tires so you
guys stay and hope you guys get down
there because there's a lot of amazing
things to do there can you send a care
package or freedom to denver for me just
yeah just to do that care package of
freedom yes that's how it works yeah i'm
also here pushing buttons in the corner
very excited to have libby back who's
apparently matching luke as he's about
to head off and leave us in the distance
yep i'm also wearing red yes i'm excited
for tonight's conversation it's gonna be
great with christian and libby before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member help support all of our
work here at the sim cast irl podcast
and you'll be supporting our journalists
as a member you'll get an ad free
experience and access to exclusive
members only segments in the tim cast
irl podcast you don't want to miss it on
fridays we do the green room show every
so often and this is where we have our
guests coming in in the green room and
they're hanging out and it's very candid
that way we can have you know we can we
can kind of mix it up so again
timcast.com support the show don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show right now the url everywhere you
can because that grassroots effort will
make us bigger than cnn and msnbc and
fox news overnight let's get into that
first story we got a tweet here from npr
more than 1 000 scientists and health
professionals are calling on spotify to
crack down on coveted falsehoods being
spread on joe rogan's podcast the
pressure highlights a trend podcasts are
becoming influential sources of
misinformation i want to pull up the
article but i want to point out the
framing technique they they pulled off
here from npr
they didn't say being spread by joe
rogan they said on joe rogan's podcast
what they're saying is
anybody who wants to interview some
interview someone who would say
something out of line with the official
establishment narrative must be stopped
it's not about joe rogan as an
individual it's about the fact that joe
would talk to someone who is considered
persona non-grata by the machine now
that is a whole new level of creepy if
they were just saying joe has bad ideas
well then you could be like well you
know he's not the expert he's the guy
who interviews a lot of the experts no
no they're talking about the people he
hosts in interviews they don't like the
fact that he gives people an opportunity
to speak up and i also want to point out
the list was originally 270 people and
it turned out only 87 were actually met
you know practiced medicine i guess
technically you could say veterinarians
practice medicine and dentists do too
but some of them were like podcast hosts
now the list has expanded they where it
was they say an open letter urging
spotify to crack down on covet blah blah
blah the medical and science scientific
experts slammed rogan's track record of
airing false claims they go on to say
the list has now expanded to 1 000
people and you know what
so what they're going after podcasts
they're mad that this is one of the last
bastions of of of unfettered speech
though there have been podcasts that
have been banned
here they go they did it to youtube they
did that big
adpocalypse campaign the media smeared
them relentlessly now they're going to
go after all the big podcast platforms
but this is crazy and just absolutely
absurd i remember seeing the 270
doctors that they first put out and it
was everywhere in the corporate media
and i was like let me just take a look
at this list and i saw dentist and i saw
a political professor i saw a
veterinarian i saw
students i saw political scientists and
i'm like wait wait
what you know these people should be
number one ashamed of themselves because
they should be challenging these ideas
not trying to silence them and i made a
post about this and it went all
throughout twitter specifically saying
these are not practicing medical doctors
now there's a thousand of them i haven't
checked the list but i still remember
being publicly attacked by a
gynecologist on twitter who is on that
list being like he's calling me out he's
trying to you know blur the lines here
he's trying to spread misinformation no
we're not you could counter the
information you don't have to silence it
and when you type in joe rogan into
google news right now you get nothing
but smear pieces attack pieces that
literally look like they almost come
from the chinese cultural revolution
with double speak orwellian language
yahoo news has an article the problem
with joe rogan and white boys the
independent these experts say joe rogan
is an extraordinary danger to society
here's why npr of course has more
blatant articles about online
misinformation again
counter the data dr robert malone has a
lot of credentials he listed his
credentials he is someone who was an
extremely important part to this entire
process that the world is going through
with this larger experiment
challenge his ideas don't take out his
tongue because when you do that you
prove him right
look at this one from nj.com the long
list of things i will not be asking joe
rogan for advice about and it's got
fauci he says i've been an infectious
disease expert for 50 years and then joe
rogan saying i get kicked in the head
for fun
yeah okay not anymore he quit kickboxing
and he's like
but it's just so stupid
anybody who's ever actually listened to
his show know that he's an inquisitive
guy who asks questions of experts that's
it if they really wanted to play games
they could show fouchy and then they
could show peter mccullough or dr robert
malone that would be really interesting
voucher would be like i'm a bureaucrat
of the past 40 years and malone would be
like i invented mrna vaccines how about
that one
but they shut down malone yeah there's
another thing about this though which is
this is what happens to any new media
you remember the blogosphere do you guys
remember the blogosphere
yeah so this was like it was a while it
was like the in the early 2000s all of
these blogs were popping up and people
were getting their news from blogs and
so you had mainstream media outlets
corporate media outlets slamming the
blogosphere like i believe the press
secretary at the white house actually
used that term um saying you know you
can't trust these sources these are
terrible sources that's exactly what
they're doing now to podcasters they
don't like anyone that gets more popular
than their own you know corporate media
outlets that's why you know that's why
it's so important wasn't pj media like
pajamas media wasn't that the slam
against the bloggers like they were just
in their pajamas at home and that's why
you can't trust them right and they
could have embraced their pants
i'm not joking that's real
terrifying i no longer wear pajamas
personally i cover late night tv
and late night tv gets so many facts
wrong on such a consistent basis where
are the lineup of doctors saying that
stephen colbert is full of it where are
they did you see colbert call for
abolishing the senate
he was like what's the point he's like
the democrats represent more people and
it's like represented does not mean they
agree with them
that's that's that's it's just it's
fascinating
they don't like their their machine
being challenged that's that's the
obvious point but they're losing
and that's why i love i love the joe
rogan joe rogan subject matter because
joe's winning and doesn't care he
doesn't you know what's really funny i
feel like joe's you know sitting on the
throne of biggest podcast doing his
thing and then mainstream media and us
are like just down on the ground
bickering to each other and complaining
about it and joe just doesn't care
how long will spotify have his back
though i think that's the big question
uh what's two years i think that will be
an average age of of of contracts you
know and then once it's up they're gonna
be like
but uh i actually making a lot of money
from him though oh yeah absolutely the
company was valued over a billion
dollars the stock skyrocketed as soon as
he came on the platform yeah i was kind
of bummed because uh
you know i was like when i knew that the
shift was going to be happening i was
like man i should have bought all that
spotify stuff
because it just skyrocketed once i
didn't even think about it to be honest
in reference to stephen colbert saying
that we should abolish the senate or
whatever he was saying it was weird
because he was like the senate is the
most anti-democratic thing but what he
doesn't understand is we're not a
democracy we're a democratic republic in
the senate is the essence of the
republic it's a stop gap for democratic
mob mentality
stephen colbert
palpatine
that's giving him too much credit though
but not as funny as the emperor right
it would have been funnier if when he
called for abolishing the senate he just
like his voice changed he'll be
dissolving the galactic senate i mean
that the federal republic he's the
gesture klaus schwab is the real emperor
palpatine in my opinion with everything
he's been pushing forward with the world
economic forum and the great reset uh
but but again joe rogan is as popular as
he is because he comes off as very
genuine very honest he has conversations
that a lot of people are afraid to even
think about and he entertains ideas in a
way that's not forced upon you in a way
that is naturally uh you know understood
and and and and just talked about in a
rational way rather than of course pr
corporate talking points and that's why
he is where he is right now
i think joe represents like you're a
regular person
she does not
for the longest time there's been this
conversation around like citizen
journalists and it's really funny
because people don't know what it means
citizen journalism referenced somebody
would be walking their dog and then see
something happen and then film it and
that's what it means you're a citizen
who happens to commit an act of
journalism but people who specifically
try to engage in journalism are not
citizen journalists but the conversation
around that was basically why should we
trust these individuals and a lot of
people said well look the suit on tv
talking to you as the authority doesn't
work anymore people have trust in
themselves and they want to they want to
talk to trusted people they don't trust
foreign you know like like outside of
their life i mean kind of establishment
elites they want a regular person they
can feel like their neighbor who can
talk to them so fauci represents the
establishment elite of we are smarter
than you and we know it and joe
represents hey man don't listen to me
i'm an idiot but i just got some
questions but there was this great clip
going around i think james lindsay
shared it from the world economic forum
in november and it was this lady talking
about how
uh the elites all are banding together
internationally and are working together
to get their agenda across but the in in
each country individually um the lower
classes don't trust the elites and she
was talking about this as though this is
some big problem
the rest of us don't trust our elites
you know we don't trust these people who
are telling us what to do based on their
own international conglomeration of you
know ideology and
wealth
reporting real quick i hate the elites
not every single person you know it's
not absolute but just like
fouchy and biden and the uniparty and
mitch mcconnell's in there these
establishments these ultra wealthy i
just
i'm dying to say something because
they're literally calling themselves i
love you guys
got closer we're a lot closer but like
everyone else doesn't like us gee
you wonder why as of course we literally
went through an entire situation why are
you playing that man
that dog torturer i don't want to be
seen with that man but they are
literally in a situation where they have
profited off tremendously off of this
entire pandemic they have created a
situation where the rich are becoming
richer than they ever have before and
they wonder why don't they trust us and
and of course their circle got tighter
and what's really surprising about the
world economic forum they literally put
out all of their plans right in front of
you they write about it they said most
about it they said it straight out they
they discussed the great reset and
exactly in detail exactly and then as
soon as we all started writing about
like oh y'all have you seen this plan
this is this crazy plan the fact checker
swooped in and it started saying that
this wasn't actually real and it's like
look at the damn documents there right
there these are they said it they said
it out loud yeah the corporate media is
like conspiracy theorists conspiracy
theories these are kinds of people
making it up but i'm like and they
literally just reverted new world order
into the great reset that's exactly
what it is and let's be honest with it
and they figured we'd all be such plebes
that we wouldn't actually notice we
can't actually read they rebranded the
new world order and they still put out
all of their documents like the medieval
catholics who don't understand latin no
we know what it says they literally try
to make you eat bugs there's like short
little videos that they put out on
twitter saying eating bugs is going to
be great and save the world so check
this out check this out on january 20th
i was on twitter and the what's
happening page popped up with the great
reset is the world economic forum's
proposal for post covet economic
recovery reuters in the bbc report and i
just
screen grabbed and put lol i thought it
was funny they keep trying to do this
thing where they're like the the great
reset it's just this it's just that the
funny thing is it reminds me of when
hillary clinton was campaigning and she
put on a southern drawl when she
yeah and like
she didn't realize the internet existed
and that human beings talk to each other
pretty old so what's fascinating about
the great reset the world economic forum
the davos group is i feel like it's a
bunch of 80 year olds who are like
how are people finding out about our
plan and the great reset it's like
have those social media watches just
tell everyone what to believe and then
regular people look at it and go
yeah that's that's bs like we're not
cows or you know what i mean we don't we
don't just get told something and go oh
but it really it really is it when
hillary clinton she put on that southern
dialect
because she thought she was going to
trick people into thinking that she was
from the south or whatever i get it she
is but she doesn't talk that way she was
a new york senator and then the video
goes viral and everyone made fun of her
and laughed and then she was like how
did i lose
it's humorous and elitist thinking that
they're above everyone else and
therefore they could get away with it
this is why the pope trudeau macron
biden kamala all the world leaders have
been saying the same thing we need a
great reset we need to build back better
they slowly and calmly tell you that
this is their plan openly and you're
deemed a conspiracy thirst for even
bringing it up and talking about it when
their plans are laid out and they're
implementing it right in front of our
eyes there's no hiding it it's right
here yeah what they mean is we need to
solidify our power exactly
i want to give them some credit there's
so little self-awareness in our culture
these days
calling themselves the elite i'm very
impressed by that that is cool
was that you i wasn't there but they
were like
based tim calling him elitist and not
elite i don't but i wasn't there if you
said that but it was the video was
actually really funny when this woman
where was she at the world economic
forum and she's like the elites she's
like referring to herself in that way
and it's just like there's one way not
to endure yourself regular people
liberty lockdown liberty lock pod if
you'd stop referring to yourself as our
elites i'd hate you at least ten percent
and i was like how bad could it be it
was worse than i thought it was going to
be you know what's funny though i feel
like
it's the children of the previous
generation's elites and they say that
you know wealth only lasts a few
generations so you end up with these
like the the robber barons and stuff and
then over time they have kids who have
kids and now we have this global elite
that are kind of like the inbred royalty
who don't really know how to run a
system yeah so they've inherited all of
this they never earned it they never
fought for it and it's like they're
going through their own fourth turning
where the ship the great great
grandchildren of these pre these past
billionaires and millionaires and and
powerful uh you know royals and
politicos have no idea what they're
doing but they just know they're better
than you that's why i'm told that's i
think we have to yeah we have to really
realize that nobody really knows what
they're doing i went i mean i went to
prep school with a lot of really smart
people who have no idea what they're
doing and they're you know running the
country now that's terrible what's the
point of being here anyway being a human
i i still don't know
that was a huge leap yeah it's like
there's problems with our country why am
i alive i know survival is like part of
it but other than that what's the point
i mean this is this is about this is why
i you know a lot of people say that
religion is very necessary to a culture
to a society because there are a lot of
people right now that have no purpose
and they're asking the same question you
are but
they're they're being given answers by
the elites who want to control and shape
everything and so they're telling them
things they're telling them crazy things
and then when these people go out and
write and burn things down they're
protected so they've found their meaning
they found their purpose but you know
the crazy thing about it
they have their purported purpose you
know with these black lives matter
groups or antifa we got to fight for
against depression and it's like have
you ever actually sat down and asked
yourself what's what's next what's after
that what do you do
it's like these individuals are just
lost a lost generation and that's where
the cast is coming from but it's being
weaponized by the elites who want to
dramatically reshape the planet i'm
concerned about the kids wearing masks
talking about a lost generation because
if i've been raised not seeing facial
expression other than a a hard thing to
navigate i know and you're bad enough i
know i'm all right semi weird but ian
the elites want to party in a way where
their servants are clearly marked and
masked and represented by of course the
face diapers that they wear while of
course the ruling elites get to have
their galas and their lovely red carpets
where they get to be free and not have
to wear face diapers well christian and
i were just talking about this because
both of us have you know send our kids
to school and the kids are fully masked
and outdoors too i have to actually tell
my kid i do this waving of the face as
soon as i see him take the mask off take
those
adam carolla has a theory about this he
says it's crate training you're crate
training the young kids to kind of obey
yeah and uh
i'm not gonna disagree with that because
give me something else because it's not
something you know when we get to the
when we get to school in the morning you
know i say to my son like yeah you know
you got to put your thing and he's like
okay time for my complicity covering
yeah
you know we joke about it because i want
him to know that it's stupid the whole
time i want him to fully be aware of how
stupid it is every second that he's
wearing it and yeah as soon as he's done
with school i'm like get that stupid
thing off your face a couple days ago i
posted a meme of you know students that
were told to be six feet apart there was
a police officer looking over them they
were outside with a mask and then the
tagline was like this is how you make
someone a slave this is how you raise
someone not to think independently how
to literally act like they're in prisons
and that's what they're doing in schools
i would absolutely recommend for you
guys to try to do anything you can i
mean both of you guys are in new york
city you guys are i'm in denver but the
same
same thing
really but but like there's probably
other families that feel like you that
would want to create a homeschooling pod
network that would actually help your
kids so much more because i feel so bad
for these these kids they have to go but
you know you know what really bothers me
is how
you know we used to see people from uh
southeast asia they wear max masks when
they're sick
and i'm like i like that idea like if
you're sick and you know it and you're
and you have to go out and do stuff like
you wear a mask now with the problem i i
see is people aren't sick but they're
they're all just blindly doing this
thing
and then what that creates is it
polarizes we have hyper polarization now
where there are people who are overtly
anti-mask and i'm just like yo man like
if you get sick you put a mask on if
you're not sick and you know you don't i
guess because
but
we're struggling to have the nuanced
conversations about what makes sense
and anybody who questions the mandate
for instance on vaccines is anti-vaxxer
right when like clearly everybody is
pro-vaccine you know except for like
there's many people who aren't
but there are people who have specific
questions about something specific the
the nuance is stripped out of it and i
think it's on purpose oh yeah they want
to they want to make you an extremist
you say hey this policy for kids is dumb
well then you're a you're a dumb redneck
antimatter but here's the thing about
making you an extremist right i mean you
have the biden administration going
after
uh domestic terrorists right they made
this their like a big
department of justice thing and when you
look at what they're going after they're
saying that if you are
anti-government or anti-authority then
you are you know some sort of extremist
these are the terms that are being used
anti-government anti-authority
extremists you know i saw a bunch of
things that were like a white
supremacist
anti-government extremist and it's like
what is this what is this about okay so
white supremacy that's bad sure
obviously anti-government
and so if you're opposed to the existing
power structure that makes you george
washington some sort of extremist
remember remember resist which erupted
in 2017
it was pretty cool and pretty mainstream
yeah for the whole yeah you resist
everything the man said for four years
whether you look and you weren't
supposed to look into the policies you
weren't supposed to understand what was
being proposed
he was in the uh government i think yes
right and you were just supposed to be
you guys entirely opposed you see that
story about the guy who needed a kidney
and because he didn't get vast that they
told him like guess you'll die that was
the craziest thing you know i was just
like
this the lady on the phone
pure evil like evil incarnate you
thought it was gonna be like a giant
demonic man with horns in a business
suit being like i am the antichrist no
it's the lady at the hospital who's like
i know you need a heart but for for
reasons we don't care why you know you
decided not to get the vaccine so you'll
die now it's like
you're crazy or that lady in uh texas
who uh the guy was recording saying you
don't qualify to take this vaccine uh
sorry sorry not the fact that you don't
qualify for this uh antibody treatment
uh because of you know the race of
ethnicity
and then the media claimed it wasn't
true they're like no one's being denied
like half a dozen states yeah and it was
part of the uh part of the fda directive
i believe one thing i loved was maude
marin in new york she was running for
city council but she recently posted on
twitter she was having some design work
done in her house and an architect
showed up to her house and asked her to
wear a mask
and
mod said no and you're fired
we're done here
you know i wouldn't want that person
working on my house either people have
lost it man you brought up that
department of justice statement uh i saw
james lindsey and joe rogan talking
about it it was kind of convoluted in
like two paragraphs is that have you
seen that tim do you know what she's
talking about something the department
of justice let me pull it up because i
know that pertaining it's like a
statement
defining who now is considered dangerous
oh yeah yeah yeah and they said like
anti-capitalists
and then yeah i think glenn greenwald
tweeted it's actually a while ago yeah
yeah and so they were like hey left
you've all cheered for this and
celebrated it's you and then they posted
the list and it was like anarchist and
anti-capitalistic you know are
considered violent dangerous extremists
and then there's like patriots or
whatever so it's like yo look man they
may like the fact they can use antifa's
useful idiots to to wreak havoc and
cause panic and destroy things and they
can rebuild but rest assured they'll
they will come for antifa when it when
it becomes convenient for them or when
antifa is truly inconvenient or when
they're done done with them when they
fulfill their agenda when they got rid
of everything else they're going to be
looking like the nail for the hammer
that they created it's only a matter of
time and the deep intelligence state has
the information is track tracing and
database and all of these people we
learned that they even have drones that
they're flying over protests they have
dragnet surveillance telephone
technology that literally gets all the
information from people's phones at
protests they have all of their data
they have all of their information they
have all of their networks and um
why wouldn't they be collecting it
when of course you have the state that
that
throughout history had you getting
really bad things yeah so it was a it
was a testimony before the senate and it
was i think matthew olson who is the uh
assistant attorney general perhaps he
said domestic violent extremists are
often motivated by ideology and personal
grievances we've seen a growing threat
from those who are motivated by racial
animus as well as those who ascribe to
anti-government anti-authority
ideologies
so this anti-authority anti-authority
which is
kind of the basis for the entire united
states that's right yes we are
anti-authority that's like half our deal
at least weren't the ghostbusters
anti-authority too yeah but but is
antifa pro-authority i mean i would say
yes
but do they think they are so are they
listening to that going live and he also
said he also said today investigating
and prosecuting domestic violent
extremists is one of our top priorities
on the front lines this is only because
there aren't enough white nationalists
and white supremacists they have to cast
they're going to short supplies
yeah it has to be everything it has to
be whatever they can find they have a
budget for arresting dissent they that
are getting that's right
in there they said like uh if you want
to criticize the government it may not
be considered terrorism because it's
considered first amendment protection uh
the word may it may not be considered
terrorism that was very confusing my
friends in 20 years everyone's going to
be like four and a half feet tall
androgynous holding hands with squeaky
voices and that's going to be humanity
because like they're just shaving off
the tall grass
everyone it's like it's eroding so
quickly you know the people don't
realize this but there's been several
cases that i've i've tweeted i've talked
about where people have been charged
with hate crimes for speech or for like
bordering on speech you know
there was a one case where someone took
a pride flag and then i guess they like
burned it and threw it in front of a gay
bar they said oh that was that was
hateful harassment or something like
that and it's like nobody was no one was
there no one watched it happen nobody
was directly harmed by it it's kind of a
dick move in my opinion but the guy got
charged with the hate crime for doing it
i'm like that's kind of crazy you know
what i mean but that's that's where
we're we're we're moving and we're
getting there was uh uh
two people were running uh or they on
like the the the new york train the long
island railroad and they were shouting
things about foreigners and then threw a
beer can at someone and they were ah
throwing that beer can and saying that
now it's a hate crime and like you get a
very serious charge for that so they're
starting to incorporate hate speech into
you know making it legal and a lot of
people 10 years ago were saying that you
know the goal of the left is to make it
so you can't hate speech would be
completely illegal there are many
proponents who have pushed saying that
it should be illegal and now we're
seeing aggravated charges on people for
you know speaking things that are
offensive and it's already it has to be
associated with a crime though in the us
whereas in other countries like in
canada what was what was the crime of
throwing a rainbow flag in front of a
bar well they have to call it a crime of
some sort right right but like arson
burning property but it was their
property
it was it was someone bought a flag
burned it and threw it from the building
and they said it was like harassment so
they make up the crime to fit how they
can turn it into hate speech or
something and what's happening in canada
and the uk already with these existing
laws is so worrying i remember walking
around in the united kingdom doing
interviews about uh you know english
people not having the first amendment
would they want to the first amendment
and i ran into a person who had his
whole life ruined was thrown in jail had
to face court proceedings because he
called someone a bloke all right and
this person that he called the bloke was
someone that identified as something
else but because he did it offhandedly
he literally was was was sent to jail
shout out shout out to zuma to a bunch
of people shout out to zubi who said
okay dude it was okay dude right that's
what he said and he got suspended on
twitter for saying it well or like or
megan murphy who said that jessica yanev
was him you know she i think she got
banned for saying yeah him that was her
whole tweet shout out to zubi for
getting his visa american visa he's
going to be around a lot more now
nice job dude
uh sorry i missed derailed the
conversation
i missed the aclu 1.0 that's what we
needed right i missed that what happened
did you change your leadership i can
tell you what happened so when donald
trump got elected
they made a ton of money off of the the
muslim ban as it was called now it
included venezuela you know in some
other countries but you know the left
called the muslim ban and the aclu said
trump you can't do this it's
unconstitutional the interesting thing
was that the banning of travel from
these countries actually advice from the
obama administration but that doesn't
matter so everybody protests the aclu
announces they're filing a lawsuit to
stop this and then all the leftists are
like yeah and they sign up for the aclu
and the aclu is like we're making bank
baby and then charlottesville happened
and the aclu defended the right of unite
the right to organize and the and then
everyone said you made this happen you
defended it and they're like but we've
always defended free speech for everyone
and the left started canceling in droves
so they came out and said we're going to
reassess what free speech means
and now the aclu is the anti-civil
liberties union because in many many
cases they have come out overtly against
civil rights and i'm not i'm not they
sure have over and over again crazy yeah
baby there's some sort of transparency
educational policy that was discussed
there's a great idea this transparency
and they're against it
but here's the thing about this so
education is now a national issue
that's what the left wanted this whole
time they got it parents are super
involved in kids education that's what
the left has wanted this whole time
parents are saying let's have
transparency let's see what the syllabus
is that's all it is let's see what the
syllabus is before the year starts that
way we know what's going on that way we
can help our kids we can know what's
happening in their classroom we can know
what they're learning and
for some reason the teachers unions are
all against this they've been demanding
for decades parents we need more
parental involvement and now parents are
like hi we're here we'd really like to
be involved and they're all just like
you know what you know back off yeah
okay that's just not safe for your kids
it's just not okay parents do not have a
right to be involved
and we all know why just don't have kids
they have yours right like the was it
melissa harris perry did you guys see
that that was an older clip that
resurfaced yeah i think but it still was
chilling it's crazy she was saying
basically the kids are not yours what
yeah she's saying kids are not yours
they belong to all of us and we need to
stop thinking that kids belong it's like
parents
you know who kids belong to their
parents especially when they get hurt or
any decisions need to be made but
everything they need to be indoctrinated
then they belong to everybody ever seen
that meme where it's like it's the drake
meme where it's my and our and and so it
like it shows shows him like going like
that it'll say like you know my car and
then under it says our car and he's like
yeah so it's like my kids no our kids
all right dick's a villain i love my
favorite one was our little pony
and like they put a sickle and hammer
next to it and everything yo these
people
i don't know if communist is the right
word no it's not it's it's a because
look what people need to understand
about fascism and communism is that
these were ideologies of the early 1900s
we're in a new digital information age
and what we're experiencing is something
different maybe maybe you can call it
techno communism or you know
techno tech authoritarianism or
something but it needs a new word yeah
this is another thing james and joe were
talking about and i promise i'm not
going to keep bringing up a watch that
episode if you haven't seen it yet
about how it's like fascism and
communism blended and it's 21st century
it's new um what klaus schwab's trying
to do with blending corporate
corporations and governments together is
basically the definition of mussolini's
fascism that's what he called it but
it's so different now that they can spy
on everything and like cut off bank
accounts globally that it's another kind
of techno
it is it's not necessarily communism
it's not necessarily
fascism it is authoritarian
but the thing about fascism is that it
was
cultural enforcement communism was just
they just took over and they point guns
at you it was much more authoritarian
and they would steal food and it was
just like it was like
the whole system was one thing with
fascism
basically i was reading this uh article
about how the nazis weren't really
socialists but kind of were because
people often say oh it means national
socialist what would happen is that
they would go to a factory and say are
you producing for the war effort and if
the guy at the factory said no we're
producing for demand they'd be like why
do you oppose our efforts and they'd be
like no no we'll we'll do it
basically cancel culture the idea that
if you didn't fall in line with with
cultural enforcement and cultural
enforcement is more powerful than
government so that's the thing about you
know the fascistic method
now i guess back then there was a big
dividing ideology the communists wanted
to erase culture they wanted to purge it
and wipe it clean and the fascists want
traditionalism so what we're seeing
today is techn authoritarian communism
or whatever you'd call it i don't know
it all boils down to the evils of
centralization and the idea that you
could control people from top down that
idea i think is one of the most
destructive ideas without throughout all
of human history and whatever you label
it whatever you call it it goes against
the basic principles of free humanity
and that of course is liberty and and
decentralization decentralization right
now if you look at a lot of problems in
this world could
solve all of them uh in in in in in an
extensive way that would reduce a lot of
harm and help a lot of people out
because it would stop the bastardization
of power that absolutely corrupts
individuals so i think that's one way
that we should start framing it and
looking at it because you know to have
this larger idea that that one person
one king should control your life and
your existence has already fallen by the
way wayside now the another idea that
hopefully progressively is going to be
destroyed is that a president or an
autocrat or a corporate head is going to
be controlling your life and i think the
more we move away from those ideas the
more we move towards freedom the more
humans will prosper and grow i got it
hear me out
what if you run for president
and when you win you get four years you
can run again for a second term
and if you if if you lose
or you complete a second term we execute
you
oh
interesting so then it's like logan's
run
knows that they're not going to actually
be benefited in the long term this is
the end you've decided because you you
know then you get someone who's in their
60s and they're like i've lived a long
life i have some ideas and i think this
is the end for me i'm gonna do a bunch
of things that i think will make
everything better for you and then i'm
out this is like i'm actually i'm
actually kidding i don't really think we
should execute this it's gonna be like a
star trek episode where the guy who
played uh the guy who played winchester
on mash ends up falling in love with uh
deanna troy's mom do you remember that
that's right and then it's a society
where at a certain age they just killed
they just kill you yeah
they have a big party or just like take
all their money away when you go to the
white house you're and you're broke
you're broken yeah actually actually
maybe maybe what we do is as soon as you
leave any public office
you will do term limits so every every
office will have like a year base so
like in congress it's two years so okay
you can run four times the senate you
can run twice it's still kind of long
you'll get 12 years and then the
presidency is too and once you're done
you lose all your possessions you get a
white jumpsuit and you go to the island
and then you just live in a community of
people who are past civic leaders and
you can never leave and you've chosen it
the problem with having four two-year
term limits is that they'll spend every
year running for the next term and waste
all that time right now but if you lose
you go to the island and so on that
island jimmy carter builds all the
houses that's right no no so listen if
you if you run for congress and win
you're in for two years and then you're
like i'm gonna run again and then you
lose to the island
but i mean i don't want them to spend
any time while they're in office
worrying about a re-election i want them
to be in run their term and then be gone
so two two two two two one eight year
term is that too much years to give
that's a good point that's a good amount
one for one four-year term
or maybe two four-year terms one
re-election maybe but they'll spend two
years prepping their real estate but
congress is two years
giving congress
four years and two terms and then once
you're done the island you know what i
want to point out about there's an
internet there so you can play fortnite
and the kids can talk another
possibility is to elect our pets to be
politicians and i bet they would
probably do a better job than all the
politicians
young gentleman made his horse a
counselor i believe and there's a small
town i believe in alaska that elected a
cat to be their mayor oh really yeah
when i was thinking about how the nazis
would go to these corporations and be
like are you with us and then they're
like no and then like then you're
against us there's the nuance in society
i think that's been lost or overlooked
lately that you don't have to be for
against something you can be neutral and
that's usually you are
99.999 percent of the time people are
neutral to the environment it's only you
don't have to take a side
and live like that make sure you live
like that polarize you know so i tweeted
uh a joke about capitalism today i said
capitalism was too successful we have
fat homeless people
so
there's there's several different layers
to this joke and i felt like it would
play well with everyone for people who
are pro-capitalists they'd be like wow
even our homeless people are eating too
much for the communists and the left
they're supposed to be like people who
eat too much still don't have homes
like it's supposed to play both ways but
it's only the left who gets mad about it
the right just laughs and they're like
whatever and the left is like offended
and and i tweeted
it's what i call bugs bunnying where you
can make you can make a statement that
should be something they'll support but
they'll criticize so you can prove that
they're they're principally bankrupt
they don't actually believe what they
believe they actually care about these
things they just want to hate another
group
and i think that proves it i've made
i've made several statements you know
like i think the the carhartt one
when the carhartt boycott happened i
said here's here's something if you
don't want to get vaccinated you work a
car quit
and i got criticized by the left for
saying that and i'm like
shouldn't you agree with me on that and
actually a lot of people tweeted they
were like but you know why are you
criticizing him he's right just quit
then if you don't want to work there
yeah well it's because it's not about
principles it's about being part of a
tribe that hates another tribe their
identity is based on hate that's it
and there's people on the right who are
like that for sure but it seems to be
the rule on the left well you're in like
like you said twitter i think the other
day uh two percent of americans are on
twitter and you're active on twitter and
you're like in it so you're looking at
these crazy crazy minority and it's like
oh absolutely it's got to be loud for
you and what the algorithms want you to
see someone left a very good comment
saying that the politicians usually do
go to an island after they
and that of course is epstein's island
but uh clever so shouts out to the
person who made it
let me pull up this story here we got uh
from the post millennial oh my joe rogan
and james lindsey point out how the left
smears everyone they disagree with as
alt-right on the latest episode of the
podcast joe rogan spoke with james
lindsay about why so many people are
deemed alt-right by the left and uh the
story's about me so uh special thanks to
james and joe because i don't even think
they were necessarily defending me just
pointing out facts just denying this
what happened was this guy josh zeps who
is a statist propagandist in australia
who really doesn't like me because i've
criticized their country and he makes
things up and boy is he triggered by me
he said you know oh tim poole says these
things and blah blah and then a few
seconds later it goes so these alt-right
guys who are you know saying this stuff
and then joe cuts him off and he's like
tim paul's not all right you can't just
say that man that's not true and he's
like well i i didn't mean i mean and
then he says i don't think magic nawaz
is all right i know him but tim poole
so joe rogan's talking to james and they
end up bringing me up specifically and
joe's like i know tim very well he's
like a centrist he was a boots on the
ground guy for vice and then james like
yeah he was in occupy so this is this is
what i think is is
it shows the the lies it's obvious
they're lying the most one of the most
powerful media uh uh
shows in the world joe rogan's show is
outright just with no uh
remorse calling out the lies i think
this is a good example of
the narrative is is breaking before our
eyes you know whatever there's i know
there's a lot of reasons why we said the
narrative is breaking but here's another
really good one it involves me so
obviously i wanted to highlight it and
say thank you to joe for for just being
honest and talking about you know my
views and everything but who's going to
believe this anymore well i was thinking
maybe this is alt right in the sense
that it's alternative to the to the
polarized right it's more of a center
alt-right means white nationalism that's
the problem with specifically that's the
problem with the phrase it does it
shouldn't mean that it's further right
than than people on the right it's just
an alternative to weird polarized
politics that's literally not the case
it just crossed my mind associated press
put out a statement years ago saying the
alt-right group that that coined the
term specifically referenced white
nationalist ideology that's where the
term came from that's what it represents
that's why the left will try to
passively smear everyone as all right so
they can then add to your wikipedia page
something like ian's been called
alt-right then another outlet will say
many news organizations have noted that
ian comma who's considered alt-right
comma and then eventually they can just
say ian is alt-right then they can then
say ian is a white nationalist and put
on your wikipedia page that's the game
they play it's not working anymore it's
it's falling apart because people are
getting sick and tired of it and they're
not scared to call out the bunk media
and you know it is as the media ratings
collapse people are getting less scared
of being smeared because they're
irrelevant
but it's also way to shut you up they
can't engage you with your ideas so like
someone said i don't want um i don't
want open borders well then you're
you're
racist because you don't like mexican
people but no because i there's a reason
why i don't think this is effective it's
it's you know racist sexist it's all the
things it's to shut us up because they
don't want to have this debate and
people on the left are
they don't they're not good at debating
because they don't get those other ideas
coming at them if you're on the right
you get all the ideas you you watch
colbert you watch the culture you read
the news you're experiencing even by
default all these different concepts and
you're able to kind of you know
work with them talk about them debate
them but if you're on the left you're in
this bubble area and you can't debate so
you have to smear well shout out to
hunter avalone for having come on this
show a while back because you know he
made i respect him for coming on the
show and he was having you know
traditional liberal views but man don't
don't come on a show unprepared and be
arrogant about it and that's what i
would say so you know the issue was with
him was he brought up hunter b he
brought up joe biden hunter biden
ukraine barisma and he didn't know
anything about it so when i said joe
biden did engage in a quid pro quo a
corruption
in ukraine to empower his son and make
money for his family and hunter was like
that's not true i was like bro i can
name every person i've read the reports
i've read ukrainian news i've read
russian news i've read matt tybee's
reporting i have dug through that to a
great deal
and i asked him do you know the name of
the guy who started charisma and he was
like no and i'm like okay look with all
due respect why would you step up and
claim you know something and then when i
ask you a simple question it's outright
i don't know anything about it that's
that's a weird arrogance that exists but
like
about it but
they don't they don't know any of this
because they don't actually have these
debates so when someone comes into a
debate and their first experience with
this is ah i remember what hassan said
he said it's not true
and then i'm like i actually can pull up
all of the facts and show you do you
want to see the ukrainian news outlets
talking about this guy fleeing the
country no they don't read the news they
don't they listen to each other and they
have a big
um circle of people who are jerks
we try to keep it family-friendly
i respect that they're very happy in
that circle but uh they're also
completely out of touch too they're on
that island to the outside
yeah yeah that's probably what happens
on that island uh to be completely
honest with you but joe biden bragged
about that i mean can we not forget that
it's amazing that joe is like thrilled
literally he's like i did it i had to
quit pro quo and the media is like no he
didn't right
that that's you got to be a special kind
of either stupid or or deceptive
to be going online claiming it never
happened when we all watched the video
of joe biden doing it and joe biden's so
dumb he bragged about it i think the
scary thing for me about media bias
today is that we can see things or hear
things
in their context and the media will say
no it didn't happen that scares me to
death
it really scares me well it used to
scare me now i just laugh about it but
people believe it though that's the
thing that really upsets you but their
ratings are in the gutter so i know
their ratings are still high colbert
gets like three million viewers or
whatever i just really loved when joe
biden was doing the press conference and
they were like you know if you don't
pass these voter reform bills what do
you think is going to happen joe's like
well there's very good chance it could
be illegitimate and then jen seki comes
out the next day no actually he didn't
say that right what he said was trump is
the problem right it reminds me of when
that episode of family guy where um lois
griffin is running for office and she
gets gets up to the podium and she goes
9 11 and they go yeah
start clapping and cheering and then
they're like how would you deal with the
economy she goes nine
11. yeah and those are clapping and
cheering she stole that from moody
giuliani that's not fair yeah and i'm
reminded of the orwell quote that we
talked about on the show previously
before that says quote the party told
you to reject the evidence of your eyes
and ears it was their final most
essential command and there's a lot of
truth to that especially when you see
them
call out stuff that clearly does happen
that clearly is a reality and i'm saying
no no no this never happened don't look
at the evidence don't question it if you
do you're a bad person you're a part of
the alt-right you're you know a
homophobic means you're a white
nationalist also if you know if it does
turn out that the gop takes a lot of uh
extra seats or whatever in the 2022 in
the midterms and the democrats then
start saying that the election was
illegitimate we're going to be able to
look back on this moment and be like you
said it wouldn't be now what are you
talking about you know it's it's like
it's just such a little trap for them i
want to give a special shout out to the
disinformation cycle it starts with the
new york times reporting that ukrainians
were interfering in the us election to
benefit hillary clinton uh it was it was
actually let me be very careful and
precise it was politico that reported
this it was the new york times that also
reported that a ukrainian court had
found that uh certain interests in
ukraine or individuals were engaged in
this behavior and then it comes to ted
cruz who appears on meet the press and
he and he's asked by um
who's the guy meet the press what's his
face
the guy chuck todd is it chuck chuck is
i don't know he's asked do you really
believe that ukraine interfered in the
election and ted cruz is like politico
in the new york times reported they did
and then you hear one of the producers
at msnbc start laughing or nbc just
start laughing and then i'm just like
ted cruz cited mainstream news and they
laugh at him like he's wrong because
they don't read the news then our good
friend david pakman does a segment about
it where he's like i can't believe how
dumb ted cruz is they're laughing at him
and i'm like david did you google the
stories they're real
but they don't read the news so they're
like those of us that read the news like
on this show we have an eclectic bunch
of people of varying political beliefs
and we read the news so we kind of agree
on what some of the basic facts are like
many of them
and then we disagree on policy positions
but that's just it's right-wing it's
just shuffle everyone into the alt-right
bucket if you read the news well we read
the same news that's the problem is
there's lots of news out there that i
don't read that never comes up on this
show or is even orbited on this show
because it's just it seems fake it seems
like media narrative i don't know i read
like i read
not yesterday morning because i had food
poisoning but most mornings i read all
the i read at least the headlines of
pretty much everything
real quick
we've cited npr we've cited nj.com we've
cited uh uh so we've hinted at mother
jones we've hinted at reuters yo we use
establishment press on this show we just
fact checked these stories like the
other day i specifically pointed out
that i used npr on purpose for one
source i use cnn on purpose if i can
fact check what cnn says and and find it
to be true i'll use them as a source to
say okay not telling me cnn's wrong
that's one of the funniest things i was
i was accused of peddling misinformation
about the election because i quoted cnn
that's the point so i could be like wow
cnn's fake news i guess but anyway sorry
no no i just i check everything in the
morning i check fox i check npr i
checked the new york times and
washington post checked daily wire
i checked through everything we ran
overnight that at the post millennial
that i didn't see do you go website to
website or do you like look at it
through a portal honestly like i have it
on my phone oh cool so like i just check
everything i don't check i always check
reuters my reporting on ukraine and
everything i read
politico reported that ukrainians did in
uh interfere in the election and the new
york times ruled a court in ukraine had
found that to be true as well that's the
new york times in politico i'm not i'm
not cherry-picking my new sources i
actually look for counterpoints there
aren't any so i went to ukraine and i
hit up a source i had in ukraine and
said can you investigate this from local
news sources and then when i reported on
it i said i don't know the the the
credibility of these outlets it's a
local ukraine outlet i'm not familiar
with but this is what they reported it
backs up what our these national outlets
politico and new york times have said so
for me for everybody here
i think the the issue for us is that we
actually fact check the stories so we
have an understanding of reality but
when
you know chuck todd and meet the press
laughs at ted cruz or his producers do
because ted cruz cited the new york
times
that's a special level of stupid coming
out of nbc
it's interesting that the and very own
brand to think that a corporation would
feed you a little bit of falsity get you
to believe it and then ridicule you for
believing it
well there's been a lot of crazy news
stories of them just absolutely
inverting reality to what is just
totally the complete two seconds
exactly and it's not that hard to fact
check it's not that hard to to look at
sources it's not that hard to get a
different side of the story it's
becoming more and more difficult
especially when it comes to using google
uh and i think they're catching on to
that but
we have an opportunity in our life where
we have this small window that's closing
where we could look up anything at any
moment and find out exactly what we want
about it that window i believe is
closing it's still here we should still
use it as much as we can two seconds i
can pull up these stories from political
new york times mainstream establishment
outlets talking about this very fact
that nbc their talking heads make fun of
ted cruz for there's a lot of things you
can make fun of ted cruz for don't get
me wrong but he wasn't wrong on the
facts so when pundits like david pakman
go on his show and he laughs at ted cruz
for being right
i'm just like i i messaged david and i
was like hey like here's the link to the
stories bro like you said to google it i
don't understand why you're laughing at
ted cruz or mocking him there's
something about this story this uh biden
ukrainian scandal that's a little vague
that makes me tired whenever it comes up
like i feel like it requires more
glucose to process the information for
some reason i don't know why i know what
you mean
it does kind of feel that way it's like
it's layered it's it's complicated it's
not a thing certain stories are just
like a punch to the face this one it's
more requires people you got to dig in
you know to explain this story to my
friend's dad i was like have a seat sir
list of characters because what happens
is you can start slow and let them ask
you questions like
a video emerged of joe biden bragging
about engaging in a quid pro quo where
he would withhold a billion dollars in
us aid to ukraine unless they fired a
prosecutor that's extortion right uh
well you can call it whatever you want
it's illegal okay that joe biden doesn't
have the authority to stop something
that's not it's not extortion if the
president does it right no but he wasn't
president at the time this was back when
he was vice president vice president and
the vice president and president can't
go and say i am going to personally halt
an act of congress so they accused trump
of doing that when in fact joe biden
literally did it and we know he did and
he bragged about it and then the media
comes on says joe biden never did that
and he wanted the prosecutor fired
because the prosecutor was investigating
burisma where his son was a chair was
like a you know on the board there and
victor shoken the prosecutor in ukraine
who got fired signed a sworn affidavit
saying the president came to me and said
joe biden wants you fired because you're
investigating barisma matt taibi
reported this and he reported there were
a dozen plus investigations from the
prosecutor into barisma every step of
the way there have been sycophantic
establishment journalists who have been
like well barisma wasn't even under
investigation and then journalists are
like here's the investigations yeah well
but those were uh not about uh
what were they investigating them for
so my clothes mykolo zlachevsky is just
uh the general surface answer is
corruption
kickbacks forged documents just you name
it when it comes to trying to steamroll
things through i don't i i my personal
view of this after everything i've read
walking the story back to explain to
like my friend's dad it's the cutter
turkey pipeline it's trying to get
natural gas into europe trying to
compete with russia and the gas prop a
gas problem natural gas monopoly it's
around 20 percent that goes into europe
comes from gazprom through ukraine so
u.s interests nato western allies wanted
to get an alternative source of fuel to
lower the prices they needed a means to
do it so they prop up this com this
company they have a guy who engages in a
little you know behind the scenes to
make it work faster there's like a cia
director who's on the board along with
hunter biden who has no business being
on the board and in the era of the
internet we can learn these things they
got really mad it was happening joe
biden said [ __ ] and bragged about it
and all of a sudden it looks like you
can see at least the surface of what
they were trying to do with syria with
turkey with iraq with iran with with
ukraine what they're still trying to do
with ukraine trump really messed all
those plans up because trump i just
think didn't care about their plans saw
the video of joe biden engaging in what
appeared to be illegal activity and is
illegal activity and then called the
president of ukraine and said i saw this
video this was literally happening he's
like i saw this video of joe biden
saying who's gonna do this can you look
into that for me and then they were like
impeach him we gotta impeach him now and
then they handcrafted this insane story
about trump quid pro quo which was
actually joe biden here's the best part
people on youtube and facebook and
twitter who named the cia guy and don't
say his name please they got all their
content deleted i had videos deleted for
telling the story i made a post
you you post any of these stories and
they would disappear without warning it
was so obvious what they were doing i
figured out why it has been confusing me
is because they've been blaming trump
for the same thing that biden does yes
exactly amazing watching it happen like
being in the news and it's like joe
biden walks over and kicks a dog and
then the media goes breaking news trump
kicked a dog and i'm like
but
and now biden is uh definitely going to
go to war for ukraine
yeah that's amazing doesn't look like
that
it's usually for oil for a resource if
it's trump or trump wasn't supposed to
win trump was not supposed to win i was
i was in uh uh ukraine at the maidan
protests when all this was erupting when
yanukovych got ousted when ukraine was
was was in that turmoil period and it
was that western forces and this is just
my opinion as one person who covered a
little bit of it i'm probably wrong a
lot of this but my view was obviously
the west wanted to get ukraine under the
fold they want to get cheaper gas into
europe that was part of the plan russia
doesn't want that to happen it's against
their interests syria's allied with
russia this whole region is embroiled in
this conflict trump gets elected
everything stops
syria he's trying to withdraw our troops
from syria they won't let him they lie
about it trump is like why do i care
about ukraine just give him some weapons
and be done with it biden gets back in
and all of a sudden oh no
it's like the amazing thing is after
trump got elected the whole ukraine
civil war narrative stops and just like
goes off the news cycle biden gets back
in and here we are ukrainian civil war
all over again yeah it's back amazing
but there's still fighting between uh
in ukraine between some russian forces
and the separatists yes but i went there
but but it was still at a standstill
compared to of how hot it was
comparatively to when uh you know john
mccain was there and i went to ukraine
uh uh i think i went there it may have
been just before trump got elected and
in this period my sources on the ground
just locals they're not like experts
said the fighting had mostly subsided
and they were no longer they said don't
call it a civil war that pisses people
off and i was like when i was here and
when i left it escalated that point
where the the eastern separatist no no
no it's just it's separatist conflict
and it's like you know it's
anti-government extremism like oh okay
and then for years we barely hear
anything about it joe biden gets in and
all of a sudden we're being told
russia's about to invade ukraine
okay dude yeah they were going at putin
until trump got elected then they were
going at trump for being connected to
putin then trump left now they're going
back at putin this whole boogeyman thing
is so annoying
well
one of the things is
you've got the bureaucratic state the
intelligence agencies they have plans
that exist well beyond yeah i think
they're playing 100-year game as well as
the ccp i think they're both playing the
100-year game trump was not supposed to
win when trump got in office all of a
sudden their plans were completely
disrupted
so anyway this all started because i i
obsess over this stuff because this was
one of the most egregious things that's
ever happened in american history a
president was impeached
over a lie to maintain
bureaucratic policies that existed
before he got in office and it just
shows you that the emperor has no
clothes no one's playing by the rules
anymore and any semblance of like
like yo if you think the president has
real power you need you underestimate
the intelligence agencies and the
bureaucratic state that that's what we
can see here that beyond the president
they they there's a reason why trump was
jammed up the entirety of his first term
because trump was not supposed to be the
guy to win and he wanted to shore up our
borders he wanted to bring the troops
home he wanted to go america first build
up our factories and he did not want to
play that international game and they
got mad about it so everything that
accused him of working with russia which
was a lie then they did the impeachment
then they did the other impeachment and
now they're trying to prosecute him over
fraud in new york so he can't run for
office
it's crazy
i have a different kind of perspective
but we don't have to
dive into all that but did there there
was a bull in the china shop aspect to
the trump presidency that does deserve
to be recognized because
i i think even donald trump himself was
surprised when he won the election he he
looked he looked surprised
like he was like wait this is not
supposed to happen what's going on here
and
whether it was underprepared or whether
it was people stopping him there was an
internal conflict that was clearly
visible whether it was him in the cia
him saying i'm definitely going to
release those jfk files no matter what
the cia saying no and those documents
never came out there there was uh there
was something happening behind the
scenes and there's probably way more
things that happened that would shock us
if we really knew what was happening
behind the true layers of power
so um it's interesting i'm i wish i
could talk to trump i wish we could ask
him more questions but
there's there's so many different ways
that the united states government is run
that we still don't fully understand but
the bureaucrats the the supposed deep
state the people that are in there no
matter who who the president is the
intelligence agencies they have a lot
more power than we think you know
kennedy assassination was like the first
example of citizen journalism maybe not
first but on video on
some random guy watching the parade and
caught that assassination and that all
the evidence from all the people like
hey maybe it isn't what we thought it
was comes from that video of where you
see him get hit sometimes
you just need a little alex jones when
he yells that an alien intelligence has
taken over and is controlling everybody
you can sit back with a nice fire going
on a rainy day and just hear the angry
rants of alex jones and be like it
actually is kind of relaxing because it
makes everything feel
like when he yelled and slammed the
table and talked about the alien
intelligence taking over it made me
laugh it kind of like brought levity to
the situation i'm not trying to say that
to be mean like disrespect alex or
anything like that but it was like my
world view is corporatist authoritarian
despotic individuals who lie cheat and
steal and when alex brings up the aliens
it kind of makes me feel like you know
maybe there's there's something more
interesting to life and it's fun to hear
the fanciful ideas and the crazy i think
for sure it's this is part of a process
that's greater than we can perceive uh
the corruption that's bubbling the
humans needing to eat food to survive so
we're constantly aggressing on each
other for food bugs
need bugs to survive
now i don't know what alex was uh
talking about specifically i don't know
if he was talking about ufos coming from
outer space or artificial intelligence
but if he was talking about artificial
intelligence there is an argument to
make here that there is a probability
that that has happened in some way i
just i just mean to say that sometimes
there's like
when we constantly hear about corrupt
world leaders and then someone tells you
a fancy story it's kind of it's kind of
you know it kind of you know breaks that
uh that humor serves a purpose yeah you
know what i mean
and now it's kind of under like maybe
maybe life is more more interesting than
just this really awful corruption we
experience and it definitely is and it's
what you make it
i was thinking about why it is you know
i can't remember what show i was
watching i think i think i was watching
uh the teen titans live action show and
i was like what's with all these
superhero movies and shows that become
really really popular how was the live
action i only ever watched the cartoon i
don't know i barely watched i just like
it's on the background to be honest it's
like it's kind of it's gory dc really
loves just being extremely brutal but i
i was thinking about something
we the the reality of superhero movies
is very capitalistic and i guess you'd
call it colloquially far right and the
world that we live in is actually like
very communist when it comes to this
what i mean by that is i'm like watching
this uh this cartoon young justice
because i'm watching hbo max basically
and one of the heroes has a laser arm
like his arm turns into a laser gun and
i was like that's just a kid with a gun
going around shooting people like he's
not a superhero they literally just gave
some 16 year old kid a gun and he goes
around he's like i'm a hero and he's
like blasting lasers at people and i was
like in the real world anyone can have a
gun i mean you might not you're not
supposed to but that's why we don't have
that stuff like power is much more
distributed so anyway i bring that up
because in the real world
there's corruption at every level like
in in almost everywhere to varying
degrees and there is no superheroes
going to save the day and end all of
this that's why when you know alex jones
says that the real enemy is like an
alien intelligence it makes it feel like
we're all in this together up against
the true evil
it's just unfortunately not true humans
are against humans when i was a kid i
remember not a kid when i was like
in my 20s i knew all these people who
were claiming that there was actually a
war going on between angels and demons
in this other sphere
and that you know we could like sort of
tap into that other war and i was like
wow you guys have way better drugs than
me what's going on
yeah i think of like um demons is like
energy patterns that can be catalyzed no
idea what this is about but a lot of
people i knew were like
demons and angels and what like a demon
is like a pattern of behavior like the
demon is in you now because you're
acting on this urge like something
catalyzes this behavior and we call it a
demon but that might be coming from
somewhere far away like a like beamed
into our like vibrating our neurons so
we think it whereas an angel is more
like it just seems to need help
this is why
dmt is such an amazing conversation why
i think so many people enjoy it joe
rogan talks about it a lot i mean we we
every so often bring it up but because
when people talk about this veil and
machine elves it makes everyone kind of
feel like there's something else out
there that this this world we experience
with all the good and all the bad isn't
just it because you know ian you you
randomly brought up like why am i alive
and that's like certainly something
people experience all the time that
question that existential question and
so when people hear stories about grand
villains they love it be it anti-fun
fighting the fascists or alex jones
fighting the alien intelligence or
people wanting to know more about dmt or
angels and demons there's got to be
something else absolutely drives us you
know i definitely do believe that there
is some kind of spiritual war out there
i don't want to kind of judge on about
my own personal beliefs but i i think to
to say that everything is just an
accident and a mistake i i think that's
something that uh from my perspective
isn't true might be a little bit of
naive thinking i think there's a lot
more to this world especially
energetically that we don't understand
yet i don't think we should understand
it but when it comes to consciousness
and dimensions i think we're only
scratching the surface here even just
with this conversation well of course we
are of course we're only scratching the
surface we've been scratching the same
surface for the entire history of
humanity you know this is why we have
religion we want to know
what's bigger than ourselves we want to
know where we come from and why
of course we do
you know
at the point when we stop asking that
question we stop being human yeah i get
confused i think a lot of confusion
comes from like it's a couple a lot of
things going on at once there's one
there's the carnal need to eat and can
keep this body healthy so there's this
chaos as a result but then there's like
this benevolent like energy intelligence
that doesn't need food it's just there
like love it's telling you love and
communicate but then you're you're
you're countering that with your body
that's like consume destroy i must i
must
take its energy to survive so well this
is the no idea what you're saying yeah
we'll watch the video again later and
you'll see it again this is the question
right the question is what does the does
the body rule the mind or does the mind
rule the body these are the this is the
question so where are your friends today
the descartes who gave you that
information and morrissey both asked
those questions
where are your friends you had the when
you were in 20's you heard this
conversation where are they today oh um
mostly they're dead sorry
christian unhappy what do you think
about dark what do you think about this
spiritual battle
i don't think about it that much i i
think my life is so frantic right now
i've got two kids my wife was battling
cancer last year uh i work seven days a
week i've uh i've got so much going on
i work all the time i i don't have time
for meteor themes like this honestly
well let me let me look at that
let me let me let me let me ask to
kind of build upon that do you guys
think when alex jones says demons he
literally means like demonic energy or
does he mean like evil people people who
are bad people you know what i mean is
there a difference i think he means
energy well no yeah like he could
literally think that there's demons from
hell coming through the veil and
latching on to people or he could be
saying that these people are demons
metaphorically like they're just evil
i think it's like uh energy tickling the
amygdala
i don't yeah i don't want to be speaking
for someone else yeah i mean that didn't
no i'm saying like how do you interpret
it that's what happened i think both
could be true
absolutely demons from the other realm
um i you know when it comes to energy
there's a lot of you know crazy things
once you start studying and
understanding it dimensions and
realities and
especially when it comes to you know the
spirit molecule there's there's so much
really to to to have this personal
journey that's kind of even weird to
talk about uh because people are going
to be looking at you strange with what
you actually believe in but uh you know
i i think everyone has their own journey
in life and has their own understanding
of it and i think the process of them
finding out
is is something that's really amazing
and beautiful and and i think even
speaking and telling people what i
believe in kind of ruins that it's so
deeply personal exactly
but doesn't that mean we should talk
about it yeah well i i think that's just
my own personal feelings on it i think
that it's very easy for human beings to
become the monster you know to
dehumanize themselves to look around and
say like you know i'm better than this
person or i get to do this horrible
thing because i have good reasons to do
the horrible thing you know but i i
think that uh
i think that there probably is evil in
the world i don't like to think that
there is but i tend to be an optimist i
tend to look at the good in every person
when i see when i interact with a person
i try and meet them where they stand and
i look for the good in them i mean i
think if you live the last two years and
don't think there's evil worlds i don't
know
where what you're smoking that'll take
some that's a very good point i mean
i've seen i've gotten so disappointed
with
people with my country with our leaders
with other nations
i i can't i can't wrap my head around
what's going on right now they're evil
there's a thing where people snap i
don't know if you guys ever see someone
snap before where they're like getting
they're getting
riled up and then all of a sudden they
just like damn like it's like this weird
thing where it's almost not human it's
like the animal takes over so you're
saying like not necessarily evil but
you're taking away people's
bodies i had some i had some weird
experiences in my life that i don't want
to talk about right now but uh there are
sociopaths right the most amount of
sociopaths per capita are in washington
dc that makes a lot of sense to me and
when you look at the science of of
sociopaths it explains a lot of the
behavior that you see kind of
exemplified in a lot of positions of
power where naturally sociopaths try to
get to so understanding it from that
perspective is also one way to kind of
answer the question of why these people
do what they do and whether it's demonic
evil
or just psychological breakdowns of
people's mental health you know there's
a lot of different possibilities out
there but i think the the spirit world
is something that um does exist and does
have a far greater impact than we even
understand it to do i've been studying
the demons from the bible the christian
bible um from this thing called the r's
goesha which is like king solomon would
communicate with demons through a ring
and it's like you look at these demons
and they're all like where is it it's
called the ars goesha if you want to
check so it's not actually in the actual
i don't know no no no this is some some
that was written later about totally not
in there but it's like ball the demon
and it's about like a bunch they're all
like kings and dukes and and earls and
presidents and stuff and i started
thinking i think these are real people
and that well king solomon was the real
yeah for sure and that i think that
demons like the archangels michael and
all these archangels were real people
and the demons were real and there was a
war and the winner wrote the history
book and wrote them and demonized them
and said that land that they all lived
in is called hell
and they remember it being a firing
flame because they probably scorched
earth
i have no idea what this is but the idea
of a demon isn't like a person that you
got to be afraid of it's it's more of a
field or like an energy pattern
that can kind of co-operate
or is it human beings who have you know
taken that leap into pure evil which i
think happens i've been told that when
you take dmt you will meet demons and
they'll offer you secrets and knowledge
and all you got to do is sign the deal
and when i asked i was there for that
conversation i remember that i asked
some of these people what is that deal
what is it they're like just the deal
and i'm like what are you giving up in
exchange for the knowledge nothing it's
just they want to share they tell you
we're going to help you and we're going
to give you this information don't you
want to be free and that people are told
to reject the deal because they're going
to you know and then the demons are like
the only reason you would say no to this
is because you're a slave and you're
brainwashed you've got to trust me i'm
good for you and i'm going to make your
life better and so the idea is from a
lot of people that these demons are
giving global elites access to
information that's what alex jones says
they're getting like privy information
or whatever from the demons i think
that's just you know when you do drugs
you believe crazy things
like this i mean this is jesus in the
desert right so when jesus goes out into
the desert and
satan offers him everything he could
possibly ever want and jesus turns it
down he turns it down over and over
again but what was he like what was he
offering him yeah he offered him he
offered him yeah he offered him power
like basically to be the king
he offered him i mean we could probably
find it but that's the one that i
remember he offered him food because he
was starving out there in the desert
because he was fasting for 40 days power
he offered him you know like
probably
i
it's maybe i'm making this up but he
probably offered him like sexual
stuff you know whatever i don't know if
that would work am i making that up that
was just everything but it was like
anything like offering like basically
the idea was that satan tried to apply
jesus with anything he could come up
with that jesus might want and it didn't
work and jesus eventually went back and
faced his face his fate you know which
was devastating and very excruciating
for him and he felt abandoned by god and
everything else and was terrible but i
think that's you know i think that
that's such a an amazing moment it's
part of why lent is my favorite
season in the in the catholic calendar
it's because when you it's when you look
at everything and you say to yourself i
am i'm nothing you know i am dust
i'm i'm you know
and you have to give up of yourself
in order to be closer to god i think
what do you think tim what's your
understanding of it of what uh demons or
i don't know or energetic that's why i
just like talking about all this crazy
stuff and that that's why you know
michael malus and alex jones talk about
dmt i find so fascinating yeah cause i'm
you know i'm like tell me your
experience i want to learn as much as i
can about this what really fascinates me
about dmt is the shared experiences that
people have reported when taking it
which indicates
that's a control that shows there may be
something truly there and look man i
would love to know the answers to the
great questions i don't know if it's
possible because we are like these tiny
little sisters it's not at all possible
and yeah yeah of course it's not
possible the universe is so massive it
seems to have something with the double
uh 64 tetrahedron and the double taurus
energy pattern that's produced nasa
impairments done a lot of geometric
mathematics to produce it's this i think
it's this shape this is a
two-dimensional representation of this
64 tetrahedron and that
life has
i don't know if there's a point to it
but it seems to be like a um like a
shape that you see the fibonacci
sequence emerge out of this shape a lot
that's a cool sequence there and you
start seeing it under particular
substances the golden ratio yeah under
dmt people see
mushrooms as well what is dmt from like
what's it's it's in your brain it's
secreted when you dream and when you're
born it's it's dumping into your brain
when you're in trouble you're you're
taking brain juice no
you're not taking brain juice it's it's
it's in our natural environment a lot of
living things have them and you can
procure it and so where does it come
from um plants okay so your adrenal
gland right or your pituitary gland
um
your third eye let's double check let's
make sure let's make sure we
get everything right here because i want
to be yeah right now
but you secrete i've never used
tmt naturally inside of your brain every
time you dream yeah and when you're born
uh
up into a certain age of i think about
seven your brain is filled with it does
this is why children have a vivid
imagination and that's why they say that
they see creatures and monsters and
entities
uh ghosts especially and then when you
die it's rushed into your brain so you
know this is something that of course
should take people on their own
individual investigative journeys they
should study this some people are like
just do dmt and i would not do that i
would say
wow study and and be respectful of this
and do their research on homework and i
forgot if i saw something like this
coming at me that's like a demon to me
that's what i see when i look at you oh
yeah
normally is that nothing that's because
ian's always dimethyl dmt stands for
dimethyltryptamine and apparently it's
responsible for like this waking dream
state you know those people are life is
a dream why does life why are these
weird like maybe we are dreaming right
oh i used to have that all i used to
have all kinds of weird things that i
saw
that's a totally different conversation
uh what's called extended state dmt
experiments now i think in england for
sure somewhere in the great britain and
um they're putting people in because
people are reporting seeing things like
this and they're coming out um and a lot
of people are having similar experiences
so they want to know why so but but it's
such a quick um 15-minute experience if
you if people smoke it that they're now
they're trying to do it in a lab in
under an environment where you can go in
on like an iv drip of it and stay in for
like hours at a time there's no puppies
involved with this is it i don't know
yet no i don't know there's no doctor
voucher maybe that's here hey let's be
real though you know when it comes to
experimentation
i'd be willing to bet that tons of
governments around the world have
kidnapped humans and trafficked them for
the purpose of experimentation yeah the
cia they did it with lsd openly
willingly uh to the point was it fauci
experimenting on orphans yes and and
other small animals wasn't uh ecstasy
created to help
swedish elderly people do their
exercises
it was like given to people in old folks
homes in scandinavia so that they would
do their exercises
it is does work for exercise i feel like
that i remember that i took it once and
worked out really hard and i the next
day i didn't have like the serotonin
depletion i i felt it tingling in my
muscles for like two days afterwards and
i felt phenomenal the next day but but
just like with anything please be
careful please do your own homework
please do your own research please don't
get tested
don't believe you know whatever you do
there's a lot of fentanyl also uh
interlaced with a lot of the mali out
there there's been a lot of people hurt
by this very severely so just again i
can't stress that's why you're saying
drugs and you don't break the law right
whatever it is in a lab setting where
they're doing extended state dmt right
this is where we're gonna find better
answers because some dude in his living
room who's like yo i talked to a giant
green elf man i'm gonna be like yeah i
knew this guy when i was younger and he
was like dude i'm telling you aliens are
real because i've seen them and then i
was like for real and i was like 16.
he's like yeah dude i went outside i was
at my friend's house and i was leaving
it was late at night and i go into the
alley and all of a sudden a spaceship
comes overhead like everybody was inside
it was late at night but i'm telling you
dude i saw this with my own eyes and i
was like wow so what happened he's like
well me and my friends because we've
been doing tons of drugs like and then i
went oh get out of here
i was like you you know what
all of a sudden i'm just like
i was all excited for some story and
then like you know ian you told the
story about the wolf you're on the roof
it was crazy and then you're like i was
high
it wasn't okay dude your story's not
true well that's like when homer simpson
that's like your homer simpson thing
right yeah it was only thc which
when you talk about high and drugs you
got to be careful because some of them
it's like like i think oregano oil can
get you high in those strong enough dose
so you got to be careful with with with
what that even
you can also just psych yourself out
like crazy like you can always psych
yourself out and see weird stuff and
like and like like
the placebo effect is one of those
stimulants
scientific effects that also is worth
talking about trypto means no the
placebo effect
because you believe in something you're
you could manifest and create something
so just by by your belief system so is
that like a rudimentary manifestation
like people on the placebo effect
actually get better in some
circumstances yes and so it's people
manifesting their health exactly so so
you know just understanding those basic
principles and laws when you implement
them with other things in your existence
this is also something worth considering
talking about especially when you have
people consuming carefully curated
social media
the boob tube the cnn imagine your
consciousness and your thought process
being affected in in such an effect
would just like the placebo can have an
effect i'd just like to say i have not
heard the term the boob tube
that's what i call it
luke and i have a mutual friend and i
was going to visit him and he lives in
la
and
la parking is it's a nightmare in this
area right and so i i'm close to his
house and i call him i'm like hey i'm
here you know where can i park and he
goes oh bro just manifest a spot
i'm i'm dead serious robbie
you got to manifest the spot and i was
like robby i'm not going to manifest a
parking space where do i park and he's
like oh dude you got to drive around
just manifest it and i was like okay are
you telling me to just drive until
someone moves and i can park my car
that's what i did
and and but then like that's proof that
he was right because he was like see i
told you and you found a spot and i'm
like whatever yeah i used to drive
around and be like robbie man there's an
open spot and i'd look and hope that it
was manifested and be like there's an
open spot and i'd look and hope that it
was and it wouldn't be and no i don't
think this is really working but
eventually you'd find an open spot and
you could claim hey i manifested it well
eventually you find an open spot because
it was there like you don't manifest
sometimes
don't ruin it come on
dude christian i gotta know about your
book it's been there this whole show and
i've been looking at it is it i don't
want to derail anything but we have like
one yeah tell me about this virtue so
it's called virtue bombs what and you
you lived in l.a is this what this is
about the internet no i mean i just
cover i cover hollywood it's going on
it's exactly what we talk about as far
as narratives but it's a woke narrative
that's just crushing hollywood it is
making things less creative it's
obviously you know attacking comedy it's
uh identity politics gone wild it's so
many things that are going
wrong with hollywood and one of the
things i'm really upset about the whole
situation is i'm waiting for that tom
hanks that denzel that meryl streep to
come out and and take a stand against
what's happening in the industry and
they won't do it they're all scared to
death why is it what do you think it is
mean it's fear you know i i i talk about
this in the book very early on hollywood
is all about fear it's like fear of
getting older fear of losing the next
gig fear of your movie not making any
money if you have someone behind you
who's better looking and more talented
going to take your role you know fear of
you know
getting young you know getting old
canceled cancer well now that then you
add this layer to it and it's a whole
new layer and they're scared they're
just absolutely terrified that's why no
one very few people are saying i mean
the adam carollo's the ricky gervais's
the joe rogans they are standing up
they're doing something about it but
they're the exception to the rule
you think like tom hanks is afraid he
might get canceled tom hanks just
decided to uh narrate a special about
joe biden's first year
you know why
not just that he's a liberal and that's
it's fine with him
his movies aren't doing well right now
he's in his 60s he's looking at things
something maybe i should kind of you
know secure my situation nick cersei
often says that sometimes actors when
they get really woke on social media
it's not about what they believe or
think they're actually auditioning for
the next role they want to kind of say
hey
i'm with you i'm in the group
this is what i believe is well come come
hire me there's like a queue right it's
called the cue rating or something is
that what it's called other sort of
approval rating so what people think of
you or something well
in like hollywood i thought the agencies
have like a number they assigned to like
celebrities i haven't you know
definitely true i haven't heard in a
while but that's yeah sort of the
popularity the acceptance things like
that i would say john cena has the best
social credit score especially when it
comes to hollywood and then behind him
is the rock that also shills for the
governor of california yeah this is this
is legit it's called the q score uh
wikipedia says the measurement of
familiarity and appeal of a brand
celebrity or company so tom hanks does
this video because he knows it's going
to get attention sure and then the
agencies are going to be like people
know tom hanks oh yeah no i understand
the whole mechanics behind it i'm just
thinking if you're tom hanks you just
watch the last year of this presidency
even if you voted for biden even if
you're a left of center even if you're a
hardcore democrat you really want to
sign on to this guy at this point well
we just watched i mean that's that kind
of boggles the mind but you see that a
lot did he get paid
who knows who knows i'm
absolutely taxpayer dollars for that
yeah absolutely the white house
admittedly bought social media
influencers on tick tock to promote the
vaccine in their vaccine effort you know
it's hard for me to think to even
comprehend that people like meryl streep
denzel washington are afraid of getting
canceled because they're so powerful
well look at scroll of johansen it's a
big part of my book is
she's very beautiful she's very talented
she's bankable when when her movies come
out they make money so she's maybe the
most powerful actress in hollywood she
took a role to playing a trans person in
a movie called rub and tug and then the
voke mob came after her
like that i am sorry i'm going to be an
ally i am so i will do better next time
that's the most powerful person in
hollywood what about other people you
know lower lower lower levels the gaffer
on the on the movie set uh an actress
coming up
what do they they think when they see
something like that happen it sends a
signal it's like with dave chappelle the
most powerful comedian of our age the
goat
and yet he's under constant attack now
because he told a few jokes that people
weren't in that some people didn't like
and he starts to falter his last special
was very much him like constantly
addressing the group oh yeah sure
as we mentioned of less than two percent
it's about one percent of the us
population who are active so you have
two percent of the us population active
on twitter about 1.2 or so are are left
because there's slightly more left than
right and dave chappelle is addressing
those people yeah absolutely and also
what's interesting about him is that
what is the message for the other
comedians you think they're going to go
near that material they're going to
think they're going to take a chance
if they could almost take down dave
chappelle and good for netflix for
standing by him and they've done that
mostly a pretty good job of saying we're
not we we back him we understand what's
going on but if you're like a club comic
and you're just starting out and you
want to kind of engage in some really
challenging topics and themes but you
don't have his skill set and you don't
have his fame
i would avoid it you might not get work
i talk to comedians all the time who get
attacked by other comedians and who try
to get them canceled it's fascinating
but the system broke ryan long is
enjoying tremendous success and growing
rapidly because he doesn't care yeah
he's funny guy yep he's existing in this
whole new you know he's not on saturday
night live he's not any he's not going
to be on netflix but he's got his own
little niche and he's very successful
he's also very good yeah and he's
aggressively a political which is it's
interesting i think about like how
figureheads are so powerful for morale
like if an army of ten thousand men is
is engaging another army with eight
thousand men but then the leader gets
killed the army will rout they'll turn
and run because they've lost command and
if like you see tom hanks bend the knee
then that kind of it's a similar morale
shattering effect on the people that
follow and obsess over tom hanks yeah oh
what were we going to say
when you were writing this did you
follow like the history of this coming
up in the last seven years or something
you know it it kind of encompasses that
time period it feels new ish there have
been there have been echoes of it for a
while but it's the last three or four
years where it's metastasized in a way
that is so powerful and so i mean barry
rice's substance page had an amazing
article recently they had two two
investigative reporters dig into people
i think they interviewed like 25 people
most were off the record because they're
scared to death and they talked about
how if you're a white male in hollywood
you're out you don't get work they
actively don't want to hire you and it's
listen hollywood has done a terrible job
with diversity and this is a course
correction but it's an extreme course
correction it's way too far
so if you if you're a white comic you're
in trouble you're not going to get the
gigs hollywood not necessarily it got
shattered by internet video i was there
in 2005 6-7 making i started making
youtube videos 106 and i watched like
the entertainment industry start to be
like what are we going to do i would get
called into auditions and then they
would google my name
for the first time in history an actor
they would look outside of the audition
for who is this guy and they'd see like
crazy videos of me and then they'd be
like i'm not touching that yeah but then
you see maker studios a bunch of
youtubers make this company sells to
disney for a billion dollars because
they're desperate for content and for
entertainment and and it's instead of
people going into hollywood and getting
contracted with paramount they're
starting up their own thing now but for
for a lot of uh you know actors that are
marketing essentially them with the name
on the title they want to you know
people will go see it because they can
pull you know those actors are
recognizable
with internet video there's a lot of
people and and the internet really
changed this there are people who have
no business in certain industries
becoming successful in certain
industries by simple virtue of being
famous you know like the paul brothers
are boxers now you know what i mean like
well they're famous they can get draw
they can make money who cares if they're
good at boxing we're gonna make millions
of dollars if we do a boxing match with
them rap battles all of that stuff so
it's the the whole landscape is shifting
and it's turning into are you famous are
you not famous
one interesting thing i noticed there's
a new lord of the rings series coming to
amazon prime
465 million dollars poured into just one
season september 2nd is coming so i
don't know a lot about it they haven't
released a lot about it but they had a a
list of the actors who were in it i
didn't recognize a single name yeah the
brand is lord of the rings you don't
need that with even with all that money
they went with a whole bunch of
lesser-known actors because that is the
property that's the drawing that makes a
lot of sense
yeah yeah yeah same with the marvel
movies they they i remember if you look
back at the old articles it was really
funny they were sharing on my reddit and
it was like marvel bets big on no names
you know was it chris hemsworth and tom
hiddleston and it was like showing
pictures of them and it was like can
these movies survive and now they're
huge
now they're so famous so they knew and
and marvel notoriously pays very very
little for their for their actors in
these movies they get paid like a couple
hundred grand for except for robert
downey jr he was getting an absolute
scene
i think it was what did they report like
tens of millions of dollars i mean at
that point he was the anchor of the
whole the whole franchise so they just
threw the they threw the brinks truck at
him so that's right
and themselves yeah
so it's great but you know what now um
like a lot of uh it's moving to
streaming and it feels like
one thing that really bothers me with
netflix is that they'll do two seasons
of a show no matter what and then just
cancel it it's just really like
spaghetti thought on the wall in a lot
of ways it's also there's no
transparency that netflix will say okay
this show is our number one show and
this is number two but you know with
movie theaters you can see the grossest
you can see what movies make each week a
lot of these new platforms have nothing
it's just you have to trust them you
know so we don't know if it's low
ratings or it's too expensive or there's
some sort of behind-the-scenes
controversy we have no idea you know
what it is it's boring
groundhog day was a great movie yeah
ghostbusters it's a great movie my gosh
but no one wants to take chances anymore
yeah and i think it was uh who was it
was it um
who was the guy who said
no one wants to take chance anymore
because you'll get cancelled and they
thought he was saying you'll get
attacked for being racist what he was
actually saying is they'll cancel your
tv show
i can't remember who that was um donald
glover maybe maybe i don't know there
was he was just like nobody wants to
take take chances anymore because he'll
get cancelled and then everyone was like
just don't be racist what's the problem
he's like no i mean your show won't make
it
like you've got to stick to the formula
so every movie is becoming very much the
same they're like let's make 12 avatar
movies because that made money let's
make 50 marvel movies that makes money
in your research do you find actors that
buck the system and still keep working
very few very few uh some comedians are
able to do that adam corolla maybe is
one of the best examples you know but he
built his own pirate ship that's what he
calls it it's his own company so go try
to cancel them although one thing i will
say about adam is that no one's even
trying anymore when you punch the bully
back in the nose they kind of go away
but if you kind of let them influence
you then often you'll they'll kind of
own you you know
tina fey is a great example very funny
lady did a lot of great shows and a few
years ago she was under some sort of
quick kind of early cancel culture
attack and she said you know what i make
it a policy not to explain my jokes
which was a great answer that's a good
policy like a year or so ago she's all
woke she's all into canceled culture i'm
so glad i'm being educated we she just
she was
basically just saying the party line
that so three years ago four years ago
she was proud and independent and now
she's been uh
i'm
re-educated
the struggle session worked and we can
all go back and delete 30 rock what's
she why what's she doing now other than
yeah isn't she deleting episodes of 30
rock you know she had i think there's a
new show that might be on peacock or
something that she might be involved
with but just i was reading her
interviews and she was talking about
comedy and the and the in the atmosphere
and things like that she was completely
transformed but it's like jimmy jimmy
fallon too he was not a great show
margaret cho is not funny anymore at all
i don't think she ever was but but i
think she was more of a true believer
even i think early on interesting
we've gone over but we have to do this
segment on the getter crisis mode leaked
audio and so this will dig into some of
our super chat time but we kind of just
that's my fault we trailed off and
talked about a bunch of crazy stuff i
could stay a little long you guys
but people absolutely want to know about
this it was in the title of the video
because we plan on getting into it with
joe rogan stuff so here's a story from
mother jones it's kind of crazy leaked
messages show getter in crisis mode over
joe rogan criticism they suggest deeper
involvement in the maga company by a
controversial chinese billionaire than
previously acknowledged i'm not a big
fan of mother jones i don't think
they're always wrong but i think they're
manipulative and they're agenda driven
and they're probably doing this story
because it's bad getter and getter is
maga but they do have
leaked audio from miles guo
they say talking to jason miller he says
we don't want to do any any bad things
to this guy rogan he says we need to
respect him just explain to him what
happened this is leaked audio about how
joe rogan came out and criticized getter
the interesting thing here is
luke correct if i'm wrong didn't jason
tell us that uh guo was not involved or
what did he say yeah i mean i asked him
directly about uh the involvement of
chinese money and and the the money
that's financing the company um we
should pull up his exact comment but
from from what i think he said he said
that you know the decisions are made by
by the company and the investors don't
have say in in you know that much in the
company but didn't he say like was not
directly involved no no formal role no
money or something like that we would
have to look at yeah we had a statement
to be correct but i i think you're right
but this is this is this is fascinating
because
i mean it just shows that there is
apparently this involvement i don't know
exactly what that means necessarily
because guo is this guy who comes out
and is overtly anti-ccp
but it is interesting because it's still
a chinese interest funding u.s companies
and uh i don't know man i don't know if
i trust that kind of stuff i'm
definitely not a xenophobe but
well firstly that it got leaked is a
little concerning because i think you
sent it to 10 people and one of those is
that what it was yeah guo sent it to 10
people that conversation and then of
that somebody leaked it that's like if
you're in your inner circle of your 10
inner circle someone's going to leak
your stuff that's that's kind of bad
news um structurally for the company 20
people 20 20. okay it was uh one-on-one
with miller and then forwarded the
exchange to a group of 20 associates 20.
so one out of 20 people
uh must have leaked seems to have leaked
that that's that's disturbing um i don't
know if it's the biggest deal in the
world to be honest i'm just wondering if
there's like it's a normal conversation
that goes on in a corporation when you
get bad pr but the question is
is this chinese billionaire
involved in a social media platform
that's trying to attract all of the
models on the board of advisors that's
what i want to know well i i don't know
i think the question is just it's not
relevant to what you can claim you can
have someone who's got no direct
involvement but you know they're
secretly running the show so like if you
if there was a leaked audio of you being
like calling steve bannon and being like
do you think i should something
something paint my wall brown would they
be like colludes with paint my wall
brown if he was like i need you in
really in relation to your last guest
you got to understand this guy needs
this that i'm like okay you got it man
okay so if it was related to the show
this show hey like if there was about
having someone on wednesday should i
and steve gives you his advice all of a
sudden you colluding with steve bannon
like no come on you just asked a friend
some advice
i guess it depends on you know what we
get out of this to what degree the
criticism and the fear is that there's a
chinese billionaire regardless of what
is positioned on the ccp involved with a
ton of american companies and honestly
i've never seen you ask someone what
guests you should have on and maybe that
would be a problem i have no idea how
you should run your company maybe that's
why my perspective is that this is maybe
more fair than it really is because i
don't have anything like this there's
nobody that i talk to about anything in
fact lydia does the bookings i don't do
it yeah
she's like not even in the microphone
just like yeah
sometimes i get my friends to come and
then there's usually controversy
and i'm like what am i doing sometimes
they're great sometimes they're tough
yeah i don't know man people were
there's like memes coming out of like
ghetto going down and it's involving me
like i'm like i don't know man i just
was asked questions i
so with this chinese billionaire i would
be very cautious because
i was thinking about it and i was like
well it would be great if he were
anti-ccp that's kind of a cool idea that
somebody could flee china and come to
the us and work against chinese
communist party but there is almost a
better chance that he's working
with the cpccp they're paying him and
he's being like uh you know like uh some
kind of spy for them i don't know that
just makes me really cautious and
worried it's basically just leaked audio
of guo advising miller on what to do
about the joe rogan situation which is
just crazy regarding the ccp like if he
works for it or not like you look at
jack ma who's a chinese billionaire he
got
ripped apart by the ccp he lost like
half his 900 billion empire they took a
bunch of his company like they he
disappeared they disappeared him from
society for like three months and then
he apologized and then he apologized
they sold off one of his companies he's
the alibaba owner of alibaba and they
sold off like half of his ali other ali
i was thinking of the apple daily guy
who also got he was like doing it a
daily in hong kong and he was imprisoned
along with a bunch of his staff so it
was totally different yeah guo fled the
country he's not in china so they
weren't maybe they're not able to get to
him or maybe it's he's a plant i really
don't know i don't know the guy yeah i
don't either i'm not confident and get
her and i you know
hate to be that guy
well it's proprietary man you can't
trust proprietary software you can't
trust people telling you yeah gab is
open source you can only trust code when
it comes to uh social networking it can
be tracking you it can be selling your
data it can be it can be feeding you
algorithmic ads and they can tell you
with a smile on their face we're not
doing any of that but unless you can
inspect the code and verify it you
cannot trust you cannot trust any human
regarding that kind of thing
i don't know to think about all this to
be equally honest but i guess it is what
it is and we'll just see more
information comes out yeah maybe it's
something maybe it's nothing maybe like
we know he knows guo and maybe they're
just talking or as mother jones tries
framing it it's deeper involvement than
anyone realized he sent it to 20
getter employees that's kind of weird i
guess woah sent it to 2015 or maybe it's
an attempt at generating
press maybe yeah or maybe they leaked it
you don't think so
i don't know
i don't think he's gonna jump on like
like the mother jones is doing it i mean
that's that's that's the template yeah
well we'll see how that plays out but
let's go to super chats because we're
we're behind if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com to
support our work and get access to
exclusive members only segments from the
podcast and a bunch of other shows as
well
let's read what we got
all right let's see
eric
what is this a raphtos of stat says hey
tim came over from crowder's show didn't
like you at first i think it was the
glasses but really love the show and the
work you do uh the work you folks do
keep it up i haven't worn glasses in a
while talking about me yeah i i was
wearing glasses for a while oh yeah yeah
because i didn't like uh
i've always worn contacts but
i just figured you know i'm not going to
dry out my eyes because afterwards i'd
go skate then put my contacts in fresh
and then i would skate and i was like it
just felt better but then i was just
like just wear my contacts whatever i
got good contacts no problem do you have
those day night contacts
no i got dailies i got the ones where
you can wear them for a month there's
like a
all the rage you could wear them for a
month and then take them out did you
ever see that like 2006 2005.
i wore for eight months i would take
them out once in a while and wash them
and then put it back in and keep because
i was broke i was so poor and uh my my
eyes get really red and like bloodshot i
blind from keeping the same contacts and
they don't sell those anymore that's why
i just wear glasses same i stopped
wearing contacts worry about that at all
it's not fun skating in glasses though
yeah well i mean you can but all right
trent lamallino says i'm already puking
no
it's gonna be a lot of puking okay i'm
sorry
i live for the we are looking we puke no
look we puke comments uh are
our warm plates in my heart
rob cochran says yay luke is leaving now
other people will be able to talk and
share what he has
me there
he found my alter my alternative account
all right what is this
little tails farm says here's a press uh
a press five super chat for luke take
care bro and safe travels to florida
from all of us here at littletails farms
we'll keep uh we'll we'll be keeping
keep we will be keeping up with you
thank you i got to figure out how to
keep the pressure on bill gates with the
smooth charm that's right i'll send you
talking points okay
all the time did you know bill gates did
this he's your insider
kai uh
kyler kasmir says hey tim i've been
enjoying the cast castle channel good
stuff i noticed you order out a lot for
the crew i think the house would
definitely benefit from hiring a chef
you are correct oh yeah we do order a
lot we just ordered a bunch of starbucks
yes we don't like starbucks for being
woke but we bought a big order from
starbucks because they ended the vax
mandate when a bunch of other companies
weren't and i said i reward good
behavior i like what they're doing i'm
gonna you know still be critic if if you
know they they come around and do stupid
woke stuff or bring it back then we'll
stop buying from them that's how it
works
but um i don't like it because it's like
if someone puts their foot on your neck
and then eventually they take it off and
you're like oh thank you so much for
taking your foot off my neck let me buy
you're a good guy now but it's like they
put you in that position yeah but it's a
little different it's it's it's the
difference is it's a big corporation
that's doing a whole bunch of things and
we're trying to push it in the right
direction right so you know if
i see your point though you know i get
it i see your point but but i want to
add at the new facility which is
currently being built we will have a a
chef
yeah so people have told me too they
don't think that you should reward
starbucks for doing something good just
because they didn't do the right thing
in the first place and they will get
woker jordan peterson says if someone
does something right you reward them for
it that's the only way to get them to do
more of that thing and i think he's
right about that so i think it's the
right thing to do if you don't engage
then starbucks just goes well we tried
but they don't care anyway so let's just
keep pushing woke where we can make
money exactly nah it's not about what
starbucks is doing it's about winning
influence winning friends and influence
all right garett says stephen colbert
lived long enough to become a villain
that's pathetic he's against the country
that gave him this opportunity for cheap
cbs bucks he's a manure spreader now
yo it was one of the dumbest things i've
ever seen when kirsten cinema who
correctly said the filibuster is like a
safeguard that makes sure that you know
police that legislation has broader
support in this country he goes no
no the side that's filibustering
represents 41 million people less
as if the people of illinois are
literally every single person's a
democrat yeah illinois is like split all
of these these blue states are fairly
evenly split except for california which
is like two to one democrat republican
so when you look at the country as a
whole
the people of these states should not be
blindly marching behind democrats
because they're ignoring conservative
constituents so you get cinema and
manchin who are like i'm going to
respect that my state's fairly moderate
colbert is wrong
chris channel says ah my gems
if you guys i have an amethyst right
here if you guys aren't watching the
cast castle vlog you're missing out
uh so it's basically sheamus and uh
chris
engaging in enhanced interrogations to
figure out who's spreading rumors about
sheamus
they put ian on an inversion table and
flip them upside down and gems go flying
everywhere
my gems
all right gems
[Music]
ray says
live live or live live dave smith he
recently made a mistake he blamed alex
jones for helping to incite the crowd on
january 6th i think dave has alex jones
derangement syndrome get him back on
with alex and alex is that true that
dave said that love dave smith i bet
he's wanting that no no no he says
okay right right but he recently made a
mistake uh alex is on camera saying
don't go to the don't go in the capital
stay out they're trying to trick you
alex was very adamantly and he had a
permit too i'm pretty sure right i think
so yeah
he knows what to do
john white says please use this for gas
to get the mobile studio to florida we
will miss luke but his nomad status is
part of the overall luke package that we
will love stay real and keep making new
shirts and words much love yeah i mean
the radowski has stordowski
we actually had our rv tech come out
today for measurements and then with the
next couple of weeks they're going to be
finalizing the new rv mobile system we
we got a different one which it's a
better system it's going to have a solar
system on it and an insane amount of
electricity so we're going to be able to
power this thing independently without
needing you know outlets and stuff so
that way we can go down to florida i
think we're aiming for mid to the end of
february because there's a couple big
events that are happening
and then we're going to try and take the
the show on the road periodically and do
like what we did in austin which was
amazing and it'll be really cool because
if we if we you know we had plants go to
the daily wires headquarters but imagine
just doing a ridiculous cacophony show
with daily wire hosts i mean just just
come to florida you know once a month
for for three to four weeks
i think it's i think would be a great
idea there's so much i mean live events
in florida would go crazy right now we
got to do it here's a good one buffalo
row says in reference the rogan letter
when einstein was challenged by nazis of
the publication 100 scientists against
einstein he replied why 100. if i was
wrong it would only take one
could you say congratulations to my wife
nicole she's expecting a fourth child
well congratulations wow
all right let's see
ian hall says bro and androgynous and
tiny disney has been pushing that for
years it's a small world
all right joseph says tom mcdonald's new
song dropped today called new world
order coincidence luke coincidence luke
mentions new world order i mentioned it
every show along with bill gates and you
know build back better wasn't there a
twitter fact check on the new world
order i don't i don't remember but i'm
pretty sure he was about how absurd our
society is
michael says modern war is 5 kinetic 15
economy and 80 percent information
erickson controls telecom in 184
countries this gets them blackmail
information this gives them power did
you realize erickson controls at t
is that true
there's a first i've heard of erickson
did someone look up that uh twitter new
world order thing i'm pretty sure they
did it it was funny
a swedish multinational networking and
telecommunication communications company
headquartered in stockholm as erickson
oh that's not the twitter thing i signed
a telephone
lm erickson is the name of the company
unvaxxed soldier says politi this is
reference sir luke luke brought it up
but he said politicians already go to
the island after their terms epstein
island
absolutely yep
i think a bunch of people brought made
similar jokes omega says in is correct
caligula insulted the senate by
practically saying that he would make
his horse a senator basically saying my
horse can do better yep
yeah but let's be real like when that
dog was made mayor of that town
everybody really appreciated it and that
cat in alaska oh really yeah yeah he's
the mayor for a long time we're like we
don't need politics
jared says tim you need to have dan
bongino on the show to talk about what
he is doing with the parallel economy
russiagate maybe even some secret
service stuff that make a great show dan
bongino would absolutely be welcome on
the show but he does his own show very
good and it's a very very big show so
you know
probably busy guy but uh would love to
have him it'd be great to have him and a
few other people maybe we could do a big
crazy show that'd be awesome
all right let's see
how hefnators i always says healthinator
with west virginia losing a house seat
merging both panhandle districts many in
my area are not happy with mckinley but
hear good things about mooney have you
thought about having mooney on your show
i
not no i don't know a whole lot about um
a lot of the west virginia politicians
because i have not been there that long
but and also i don't know you know
to get into local like
well maybe let's put it that way i think
maybe that'd be a good idea actually and
talk about west virginia because
everybody talks about florida new
hampshire and texas and i think west
virginia does some good stuff too and
they can do a lot better and maybe by
bringing some of these people on and
asking these questions west virginia can
do even better and then everyone's going
to be like i can't believe you made
america florida luke you should make
america west virginia
west virginia is awesome man i uh look
i i guess it's because i grew up
in a in a more similar climate than you
know florida is tropical i just it's not
my thing if it wasn't for florida there
would be lockdowns there'd be mandates
there was the only state that first
stood up against all of that
the fight is there no florida i mean
desantis on the on the large scale
especially with the corporate media the
attention was all on florida they were
saying it was going to be a bloodbath
they made the first stand they made a
very strong one so the fight is there
there's an election there there's a lot
of energy there it's going to get
absolutely crazy so that's my personal
belief i want to invest and build
especially with the bitcoin community
down there in miami there's a lot of
incredible things puerto rico too
absolutely
jay stewart says wait they gave cyborg a
laser no no no it's a freaking sonic
canon not a laser not a gun it's a
souped-up megaphone writers get your own
lore correct or stop writing jay jay
whoa whoa slow down there i was talking
about arsenal not cyborg arsenal is the
original roy harper who was frozen by
lex luthor and then the clone went on to
become red arrow but uh because of the
freezing i guess he lost his arm or
something so they gave him a robot arm
which could shoot lasers and i was
watching that and i'm like it's just
some kid with a gun like could you
imagine if like we're superheroes and it
was just teenagers with guns like we
would think that's really messed up yeah
i liked cable you know it from x-force
oh he's cool he's had a big rifle but he
also had cyberkinetic powers couldn't
could he absorb energy or no he didn't
did he i don't i don't think he knows
what was his power he was telling like
psychokinetic he could move stuff with
his mind really yeah i think that's it
yeah do you know one of the things when
you have kids now one of the things you
have to tell them is not to make any
jokes about school shootings
or kids oh yeah guns don't eat a pop
tart into the shape of a gun you'll get
nothing or draw one yeah no yeah if we
we talk about that wow that's crazy when
i was a kid and the teacher was talking
i'd be drawing little doodles of stick
figures fighting and like firing guns at
each other and you know flamethrowers
fighting dragons
now you'll just get kicked out of school
you'll go to jail
literally they're scared
my son and his friends joke about how
frying pans are actually the best
weapons
okay
all right caleb says yo i would love to
smoke a fatty with ian and just ask him
random theological questions and let him
go it would be like winding up the
symbols monkey at and let home bang away
at the stranger and i'm sorry if i if
i'm doing it and stop and i'm not
listening to you for a second it's tough
to like channel your feelings and your
thoughts and still listen to your
environment but that if you can master
the two of them together or like
impulsively
happening back and forth really quickly
you know it's like playing in a band
with someone you want to take control
and speak your the truth but also
be listening to their truth
and make it blend
so let's let's do that
all right hi on the first
first thessalonians says the bible
foretells of the new world order in
daniel chapter 2 and 7 12 revelation 13
if it was right about the technocratic
takeover of humanity it is for sure
right about jesus christ
i will say man when i when i learned
about the mark of the beast
you in order in order to buy sell or
trade you need the mark of the beast
someone super chatted thus
that to us and i was like there's no way
it's that specific that's crazy and then
i looked and i was like whoa that's true
that's crazy that it says that man
because that's basically what was
happening what if it's all true do you
guys think it's true do you think it's
true the whole revelation revelations
revelations
revelations
yeah
um so uh i was looking at a passage last
night and i think that people wildly
misinterpret revelation including
christians so i don't think there's any
kind of consensus on that book it is
crazy it reads a little bit like a drug
fueled dream
so i don't think that we're going to
understand it until you know maybe until
we go to heaven or something i don't
know until after it happens you can go
oh there it was yeah exactly because
otherwise people are like could it be a
lot of people were saying that like some
alignment in the sky was like some
reference that was happening or
something just kind of suits their
interpretation at this point
john says shout out to my girl libby
admire your faith you are a class act
oh thanks there you go she's a classy
broad do you guys see that joe rogan had
robert epstein on the show no
yeah he's the guy who talks about how
google manipulates the system and can
change votes yes so the one free man
says robert epstein didn't kill himself
oh gosh
[Laughter]
wow
i don't know if you can make those
shirts just yet luke hold on to that
thought hopefully
you never have to be honest yeah that's
a scary thought
david says did you hear aaron rodgers
call out biden and his super duper 81
million votes and how biden called him
out on getting vacs on espn today
uh there was some like statement by
aaron rodgers was amazing he was like
talking about censorship did you guys
see that
yeah he was just like when are the
people censoring information and trying
to restrict thought the good guys
they're not yeah they're never the good
guy he's been on fire
when you get personally bitten by the
situation by the narrative you come
roaring back it's like joe rogan i think
that cnn uh horse de warmer thing i
think that really kind of lit a fire
under him you know it's interesting
though uh i don't know if it's
interesting but we don't
we'll be the judge of that
we don't see a lot of women doing this
speaking out fighting back pushing back
against hollywood against these woken
arrows take it rolling as just by
standing yeah i mean by standing her
ground she has for sure i agree but
shout out to aaron rodgers and also
kyrie irving i usually have their
jerseys behind me uh and they both of
them have been doing really amazing and
i'm going to i'm going to get a love
poster
yeah i'm gonna get a big sweet meatloaf
poster yeah so when i when i heard the
news i posted uh the song kickapoo from
tenacious d which is a great song and
it's a hilarious movie you guys know
this one meet love sings along with uh
with jack black
love that movie man and it's uh and and
meatloaf was a was a good dude he
believed in freedom much respect so
we'll uh we'll get a poster for him up
here
john says my dad thinks you're a grifter
and puts you with handy and tucker it's
a shame he did finally admit fauci is
corrupt and needs to go though uh i'm
not the biggest fan of hannity
i don't think so you know hannity to me
feels canned i don't know if grifter is
the right word tucker i think is legit i
think tucker believes what he believes
and the reason i think that is because
his opinions have changed he's admitted
he was wrong about a lot of things he
has no reason to do that unless i guess
he's grifting or whatever but i don't
see it he's actually gone further than i
would expect him to based on a lot of
things he said and he's also resisted
saying some things that could have made
of money made him money i think tucker
legitimately started talking to people
and had some you know political uh
changes
as for me it's funny because my politics
are like the same for the most parts of
the second amendment
the people who've like followed me for
the past 10 years or whatever like he
just says a lot of the same stuff over
and over again it's boring
but for people who don't watch it
they're like someone on the left said
you're a grifter so it must be true so
your view on the second amendment has
changed
yeah i used to be kind of like
uh you know people should have right to
have guns but i think there's like a
discussion we can have about you know
gun ownership and what makes sense
you're like [ __ ] now okay yeah i used to
i used to be like well it's kind of big
no i used to be like maybe there's
insurance you know would make sense
maybe that could help people
and then
i had a few conversations
and then my point my view basically
became well the constitution says it so
if you want to change it change
constitution yeah if that being said
then there should be no nfa there should
be no etf there should be none of these
things
it just feels like the democrats and the
anti-gun people the authoritarians it's
basically the authoritarians if you want
to take guns away you're just a crackpot
desperate that's that's it anybody who
believes in freedom is going to be like
you should have a right to have a gun i
think that tabletop fusion is like here
and they're afraid to give people that
power it's like a big that given them a
rocket launcher but like it's so easy to
fuse hydrogen with a palladium substrate
heavy hydrogen deuterium like they're
doing it they do it experimentally but
it produces so much you ever hear about
that dude who made a death a radioactive
death laser in his garage no he was
taking the um
what is it called americium is that what
i pronounce it no the element look it up
for him i don't want to pronounce it you
take it out he's taken out of smoke
detectors i guess that's radioactive and
then he made a gigantic critical mass
with like tens of thousands or something
like that and then
the feds dropped in on him immediately
and arrested him but apparently they
gave him i read the story they gave him
a chance to work with the government
like if you want to do this we'll put
you in a lab we'll fund everything you
do what they did was crazy and so he
went out and started trying to make a
radioactive critical mass and he was
like covered in lesions you can't ladies
and gentlemen read the story avoid that
was that his name
i don't know guy who diligently amassed
radioactive material by collecting small
amounts from household products that
makes sense right yeah something i read
somewhere yeah this is it's amer
american
american american or something 241 is
used as a radio nuclide in the in this
type of smoke detector is it radioactive
is it on your periodic table of the
elements yes number 241 is that right i
think it's a synthetic well you have it
right there placed between two
electrically charged plates so there's
nuclear
yeah apparently he like put them all he
mashed this critical mass into a uh
some kind of metal box or lead box that
had a hole in it so it was all focused
and then they like gosh they they knew
he did it as soon as he did it and they
like that armed it like what are you
doing
like you say the people that are hiding
the information are not are never the
good guys but i wonder like if someone
came out and was like oh and by the way
if you want to create world-ending
explosives here's how like that wouldn't
be a good guy either necessarily aren't
the blueprints for like nuclear bombs
just on the internet like can't you just
read it in university it's just you
don't have the infrastructure to build
something like that yeah but this guy's
apparently crazy yeah anyway
that was fun um hey man thanks for
hanging on this crazy friday night we
kind of went all over the place but i
think it was worth it so go to
timcast.com be a member support our work
we we rely on your support we are not
principally funded by ads as much as
some of the activists lie about we're
actually funded by you guys this makes
everything operate so we really support
we require we we appreciate your support
at the website smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends you can follow us at
tim cast irl basically everywhere you
can follow me at tim cast and uh do you
want to shout anything out christian
yeah my new book is virtue bombs how
hollywood got woke and lost at seoul is
it where can they get it everywhere
amazon you name it oh right on you have
a social media at all or anything yeah
at hollywood in toto on twitter and uh
my podcast is right on hollywood right
on you want to show anything out loud
yeah i'm libby evans i'm at the post
millennial you can help us out by
subscribing coming reading our articles
checking it out
and we're at the postmillennial.com
slash contribute if you want to help us
out that way and i'm on twitter at
libyamans
so i have my own media organization
called we are change you can watch my
videos on youtube.com forward slash we
are change i also have a lot of pretty
exciting weird huge unusual things going
on on lukeuncensor.com and uh it's going
to be hard to leave but uh you know deep
down i am a polish florida man
and uh never forget freedom somewhat
someone said this before i forgot
exactly who but freedom is the oxygen of
the soul so thanks for that i'm going to
miss you luke it's going to be it's been
fun the last few months last year or
whatever it's been uh but i know you're
going to make florida great
so i'm glad you're going
and i'll see you soon bye everyone i'm
ian crossland check me out ian
crossland.net i'll see you later i had
fun on this last show with luke talking
about everything from caligula's horse
well my truck may break down by the way
oh my truck breaks down i'm going to be
coming right back
there's other situations practically i
hope i you never know what rv life is
well we hope that luke's able to make it
down to florida because that's where he
really wants to try to get rid of me
linda yeah you know just a little no
just kidding um anyway you guys can
follow me on twitter at sourpatchlist we
will see you all well we'll see in the
cass castle vlog at youtube.com cast
castle tomorrow because we have an
episode up every single day other than
that we'll be back on monday thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you